[Música]
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y a partir de este momento estoy
con ustedes en france 24 para continuar
con el cubrimiento especial del ataque
armado de rusia a ucrania desde las 10
de la noche hora de bogotá quito y lima
a nuestro equipo periodístico ha dado
seguimiento ininterrumpido y en directo
al avance del conflicto bélico y en la
siguiente hora estamos esperando
declaraciones del g7 del presidente de
eeuu joe biden y del premier británico
boris johnson asimismo estamos a la
espera de más reacciones internacionales
comenzamos pero antes vamos con nuestros
titulares
[Música]
rusia ataca ucrania vladímir putin y
dijo que no tenía más opciones que
realizar la operación militar luego de
intentos diplomáticos infructuosos el
mandatario dijo que moscú sigue siendo
parte de la economía global en
referencia a las sanciones anunciadas
la ofensiva militar que inició en casi
todas las zonas de frontera de ucrania
se extiende con múltiples bombardeos y
miles de personas intentando evacuar
después de que vladimir putin anunciara
el ataque en favor de los separatistas
de donges que y los hanks en kiev las
autoridades decretaron toque de queda
sobre la crisis se reunieron en el g7 y
la otan
y en varios países de europa los
ciudadanos rechazaron el ataque ruso y
pidieron protección para sus seres
queridos en ucrania españa alemania y
turquía están entre los países escenario
de movilizaciones tenemos reporte desde
estambul
comenzamos y damos sin más demora paso
al primer ministro británico boris
johnson que a esta hora hace
declaraciones estamos en directo
y llegaba a concluir que putin siempre
estuvo determinado a atacar a su vecino
sin importar lo que hiciéramos ahora lo
vemos
cómo es el realmente
un agresor manchado de sangre que cree
en la conquista imperial yo estoy
orgulloso de ser todo lo que están
nuestras capacidades para ayudar a
lograr y prepararse para este
enfrentamiento estamos orgullosos de
poder ofrecer más ayuda mientras
nuestros amigos defienden mucho su madre
patria hemos tomado la precaución de
localizar la embajada al ife en el oeste
de ucrania y el embajador simons sigue
trabajando con las autoridades
ucranianas
y respaldando a ciudadanos británicos
ahora tenemos una misión clara
diplomáticamente políticamente
económicamente
eventualmente militarmente
este eso está bárbara empresa de
vladimir putin debe terminar en el
fracaso
en el encuentro de siete esta tarde
acordamos trabajar en unidad para
maximizar el precio económico que putin
pagará por su agresión
y
acabar con la dependencia colectiva de
rusia del petróleo y del gas
esto ha pasado por mucho tiempo
doy la bienvenida a la decisión de
detener la certificación del 900 señor
vocero de los países que hoy reúnen la
mitad de la economía el mundo ahora
están
ejerciendo una máxima presión económica
solo país que ejerce el 2%
esa parte del reino el reino unido está
ejerciendo la mayor cantidad y las
acciones fuertes que el mundo ha visto
con nuevas medidas financieras no habrá
nuevos poderes para hacer blanco de las
finanzas rusas en adición a los bancos
que ya hemos sancionado hoy en concierto
con eeuu estamos imponiendo bueno
congelamiento completo en los bienes de
ruiz éstos pueden les permitirán excluir
completamente a los bancos rusos
del sistema financiero del reino unido
por supuesto es uno de los mayores de
europa
impedirles que accesen a la
libra esterlina y los pagos
desarrollados atrás del reino unido-
manejando la mitad del comercio ruso en
dólares me complace decir que eeuu
también está tomando medidas similares a
estos poderes también nos permitirán
vetar al estado ruso y las empresas
privadas rusas de reunir fondos el reino
unido
esperemos que se hagan préstamos a
miembros y meteremos la cantidad de
dinero que los rusos podrán depositar en
las cuentas del reino unido y también
habrá sanciones aplicadas al reino unido
por su rol en el asalto sobre ucrania
en general estaremos impuesto
congelamiento de bienes en más de 100
nuevas entidades e individuos sobre los
cientos que ya hemos anunciado
esto incluye a todas las mayores
empresas manufacturadores que respaldan
la fábrica de guerra de putin también
estamos vetando aeroflot del reino unido
es
sobre estas medidas financieras y en un
acuerdo completo con estados
y la unión europea presentaremos las
nuevas restricciones comerciales
y controles de exportación más estrictos
similares a los de los estados unidos
estaremos presentando una legislación
para vetar las exportaciones
de todos los
ítems de doble uso de
rusia incluyendo alta tecnología que
puedan afectar el sectores como la
tecnología las electrónicas de
telecomunicaciones y lo aerospacial a la
legislación para implementar esto será
implementada la próxima semana
estas sanciones
reducirán las capacidades militares
industriales de rusia de aquí y durante
años
también estamos creando medidas para la
riqueza
y también estamos y estaremos detallando
mayores detalles antes de la pascua
la siguiente acta como comprenderá todo
lo anunciado
junto a los
estableceremos
una nueva
una fuerza en contra de la cleptocracia
para buscar políticos corruptos bienes
corruptos que están ocultos en el reino
unido y eso incluye a los oligarcas en
londres que no podrán ocultarse a ningún
lado señor vocero sé que esta cámara
tendrá un gran interés en el potencial
de alejar a rusia del sistema swift
puedo confirmar lo que siempre he dicho
y nada está fuera de la mesa
pero por todas estas medidas para que
todas estas medidas sean exitosas es
vital
contar con la unidad de nuestros socios
la unidad en el g7 y en otros foros
ser voceros
los inversionistas rusos
ya están dando su veredicto sobre la
sabiduría de las acciones de putin y
hasta el momento las acciones rusia han
disminuido al menos en un 45 por ciento
de su precio
en el mayor declive de un día en el
registro de la historia
esperaban que el mayor prestamista de
rusia haya caído un 45% castró hay caído
un 39 por ciento mientras el rublo
ha caído a puntos bajos récord a
comparación del dólar seguimos en una
misión sin ningún tipo de remordimiento
de alejar a rusia de la economía mundial
día tras día semana tras semana por
supuesto utilizaremos la posición del
reino unido- en cada foro internacional
para condenar
las agresiones en contra de rusia
y haremos contra la avalancha de
mentiras y desinformación del criminal
hablar de la verdad de putin de su
guerra de agresión de su elección
y también entendemos la necesidad de
proteger otros países europeos que no
son miembros de la otan y que podrían
volverse blanco del bueno del repertorio
de agresiones de putin y nosotros
resistiremos
cualquier tentación de aceptar lo que
sea que putin está haciendo hoy
no puede haber ningún tipo de
normalización ni ahora ni en un mes ni
en los años que vienen debemos
fortalecer las defensas de la otan cada
vez más hoy le pido una reunión a los
líderes de la otan esta tendrá lugar
mañana
estaré
hablando con los países que se unan a
esta fuerza conjunta expedición liderada
por el reino unido- y reúne a la otan y
a otros miembros no tan
el último sábado advertí que esta
invasión
tendría consecuencias globales a nivel
económico esta mañana esta crisis
se ha develado
haremos sólo posible para acoger a
nuestro pueblo de las repercusiones al
costo de la vida y por supuesto estamos
listos a propio listos para proteger a
nuestro país de cualquier amenaza
incluyendo en el ciberespacio
por encima de todo la cámara debe
entender
una fuerte verdad ahora vivimos en un
continente donde un poder expansionista
está desplegando una de las mayores
maquinarias militares del mundo está
tratando de retrasar el mapa de europa
en sangre y conquistar un estado
independiente
por la fuerza es vital para la seguridad
de cada nación
que esté en esa empresa es cualidad de
putin te va a fracasar
debemos verla fracasar sin importar lo
mucho que dure
esa será la meta incesante del reino
unido
a cada miembro esta cámara y cada uno de
nuestros aliados ciertamente juntos
tenemos el poder y la voluntad de
defender el curso de la paz ante la
injusticia como siempre hemos hecho y le
digo a la gente de arroz yo de nuevo
cuyo presidente acaba de autorizar una
agresión en contra de un pueblo eslavo
hermano no puedo creer que este horror
esté siendo hecho en nombre de ustedes o
que ustedes realmente quieren el estatus
de paria que esta acción le brindará al
régimen de putin ya nuestros amigos
ucranianos en este momento de agonía yo
digo que estamos con ustedes y estamos
del lado de ustedes su derecho a elegir
su propio destino es el derecho que el
reino unido- y nuestros aliados siempre
defenderemos y en ese espíritu estoy con
ustedes al decir eslava ukraine
quiero la palabra la cámara ahora le
pido el piel de la opinión de la
posición que instar ver
muchas gracias señor vocero en esta hora
oscura
nuestra determinación están del lado del
pueblo ucraniano y las tropas invasoras
eran las declaraciones del primer
ministro británico o boris johnson de
quien dejó sobre la mesa una opción
militar eventual dijo que la misión de
putin en ucrania debe fracasar y que
debe pagar un alto precio económico
alejándolo de la economía mundial
también es dijo que debe acabar en la
dependencia de los combustibles rusos y
que se ordenará un congelamiento
completo de los bienes de rusia así como
que habrán de sanciones a empresas que
tengan en relación o respaldo al
presidente vladimir putin así como más
controles de exportación
y una declaración en la que será
necesario proteger a los países aunque
no sean parte de la otan después de
escuchar las declaraciones del premier
británico vamos a conectar en reino
unido con nuestra corresponsal luisa
pulido para más detalles luisa buen día
para usted
buenas tardes angela un discurso
absolutamente fuerte del primer ministro
boris johnson ha iniciado ante su
comparecencia a la cámara de los comunes
en el parlamento británico diciendo que
vladimir putin nunca podrá limpiarse las
manos de sangre por lo que está
sucediendo en ucrania ha sido un
discurso fuertísimo ha anunciado
sanciones sin duda sin precedentes ha
anunciado que el sistema bancario ruso
será congelado aquí en el reino unido-
para darles un antecedente bien
importante el sistema financiero
británico el distrito financiero de esta
ciudad en la city de londres es el más
poderoso y grande del mundo gran parte
de las transacciones internacionales se
mueven por la llamada city de londres
así que ahí la importancia ha dicho el
primer ministro que lo que busca es
atacar los objetivos económicos de rusia
que puede ser el lugar donde más le
duele el presidente vladimir putin
también ha hablado de congelar los
bienes y atacar a personas cercanas a su
círculo y es que lo que se busca es
también frenar que londres siga siendo
conocido como el centro de operaciones
de los oligarcas rusos de personas muy
cuestionadas con negocios en rusia y que
viven en este país parte de esas medidas
que habían empezado a ser anunciadas
desde la semana pasada se acabaron las
llamadas pizzas doradas eso significa
que los multimillonarios que anunciaban
inversiones grandes en este país
recibían un tratamiento especial con
visas pero lo que sucedía era que por
ejemplo ciudadanos rusos las utilizaban
para atraer sus fortunas de dudosa
procedencia
addis o boris johnson también que hay
que controlar aún más las exportaciones
de rusia hay que reducir su capacidad
económica
pueden medidas que frenen su riqueza
alejar a rusia de la economía mundial a
esa es una frase bien bien importante
también ha dicho que el reino unido está
trabajando en todos los frentes
tecnológicos cibernéticos para evitar
que haya una agresión al pueblo
británico ha dicho que están listos para
cualquier amenaza y que putin lo que
está tratando además es rearmar el mapa
de europa por las armas un discurso
completamente fuerte acá tengo otras
medidas hay que empezar a angela
desglosar todos estos grandes anuncios
sin duda sin precedentes para el reino
unido ha dicho el primer ministro que
van a congelar los bienes de los bancos
rusos incluido el beat tv también va a
haber una legislación especial para
atacar el gobierno ruso y las compañías
de ese país así que estas son las
medidas que el gobierno británico está
anunciando por supuesto en este momento
continúa el debate en la cámara de los
comunes hablará seguramente los partidos
disculpas
hablarán seguramente los jefes de los
partidos de posición que en este debate
sobre la situación en ucrania ucrania
están mostrando unidad sobre cómo debe
actuar el reino unido porque
especialmente debe protegerse la
democracia
claro luisa y ahora la expectativa que
se genera a nivel internacional es de
qué manera se van a cumplir estos
anuncios o estas amenazas que está
haciendo o boris johnson y bueno a las
que se están sumando otros países de
europa por ejemplo y le quiero preguntar
es difícil de predecir es difícil de
saber hay que esperar los anuncios pero
boris o de johnson él dijo que no se
descartaba una opción militar eventual
usted cree en qué términos se daría esta
opción militar de que menciona a boris
johnson porque los países europeos
incluidos reino unido han sido muy
claros en que no harán una intervención
el ica en ucrania
si el reino unido- hace varios años está
dando entrenamiento militar a las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas el primer
ministro ayer en el parlamento dijo que
una de esas opciones para seguir
apoyando el fortalecimiento de la
institucionalidad en ucrania será con
apoyo militar armas probablemente no hay
claridad exactamente eso qué significa y
a partir de cuándo sería pero eso por
supuesto es una opción que está en este
momento sobre la mesa ha dicho boris
johnson que hay que actuar de manera
rápida y actuar por todos los frentes
para evitar que el propósito de vladimir
putin se cumpla así que por supuesto esa
es una opción que está sobre la mesa
pero todavía en estas alturas no se
conocen los detalles exactos boris
johnson ha empezado a anunciar las
sanciones económicas porque el gobierno
británico ha identificado que el
objetivo principal es justamente golpear
los intereses económicos de putin para
evitar que siga en su ascenso y en su
invasión a ucrania así que esas son las
primeras sanciones sin precedentes
porque tocan el sistema bancario habrá
que analizar con y desmenuzada mente lo
que significa no solamente para el reino
unido sino para todo el mundo que los
bancos rusos estén congelados aquí en el
reino unido habían angela también sido
criticada las primeras medidas del
gobierno británico contra rusia pero
está sin duda no tienen precedentes son
son bien importantes porque no solamente
está atacando donde están los recursos
rusos sino también al círculo cercano de
vladimir putin se ha dicho mucho que
gran parte de esos amigos de putin del
círculo cercano del kremlin viven aquí
en londres pues luisa le agradezco y más
adelante volvemos con usted cuando haya
reacciones
estamos en transmisión especial de
france 24 por el ataque ruso sobre
territorio ucraniano en que está nuestra
enviada de especial e irene sabio irene
gracias a ustedes por favor cuéntenos
actualice no sé cuál es la situación en
el país que está pasando en kiev
pues lo que hemos visto durante el día
de hoy ha sido un presidente que ha
pasado de
dar un discurso
pacificador visitando los rusos a
recordar que los ucranianos son sus
hermanos que ucrania quiere paz y que no
quiere la guerra que en europa no
necesita otra guerra a un presidente que
ha dicho que ha pedido al ejército de
atacar con la mayor fuerza posible de
provocar la mayor número de bajas
posibles a las fuerzas rusas y lo último
de ahora es su petición de donar sangre
esta evolución también se ha visto en
las calles esta mañana cuando oímos
las primeras explosiones a quien quiere
sobre las 5 de la mañana la gente
realmente estaba probablemente todavía
en una fase de negación es por tanto
todavía se veía a gente caminando
viviendo una vida relativamente normal
en las calles aquí de la capital de
ucrania ahora mismo es de noche pero
hace unas horas
las calles se vaciaron completamente las
tiendas están cerradas las cerraron y
la verdad es que se ve
una desolación y vicent sin duda hay un
silencio bastante impresionante por otra
parte hay que decir que como ya han
contado la realidad es que en los
ucranianos todavía no saben el asombro
de este de este ataque sobre todo en lo
que respecta a la ciudad de quiebre es
un ataque que realmente nadie vio venir
bueno irene usted que está en el lugar
que está en el terreno y que recibe las
noticias locales pues cuéntenos por
favor sobre las recientes declaraciones
que dio el presidente de volodymyr
selenski y sobre todo cómo se ha tomado
el estado de ley marcial en el país y en
kiev después de que por ejemplo el
alcalde ordenó el toque de queda y
ordenó que algunas estaciones de metro
funcionaran eventualmente como un lugar
de protección ante posibles
bombardeos
pues la verdad es que en estos momentos
ha estado el gobierno está ocupado sobre
todo con la
situación bélica las acciones militares
rusas en todo el territorio ucraniano y
los ciudadanos ucranianos están
respetando lo que el gobierno les está
diciendo
algunos eso es cierto esta tarde durante
todo el día han intentado y algunos
también lo han logrado irse de la ciudad
lo que ha provocado
embotellamientos
en las afueras de kiev por otra parte
otros han estado incluso manifestante ha
habido un grupo de mujeres aquí delante
del hotel ucrania que se ha manifestado
pidiendo que por favor el mundo ayude a
ucrania
y no
desmoronarse completamente ante esta
guerra y en lo que concierne los
refugios antiaéreos
los haya centenares en toda la ciudad
los ciudadanos están enterados de estos
refugios saben que cuando se dispara la
alerta antiaérea
deben ir a estos lugares y tienen
también mochilas con mantas térmicas
linternas
a bajas americanas y otros objetos que
sirven para sobrevivir unas horas o
quizás también unos días en estos
lugares pues mire irene le pediré que se
quede con nosotros conectada para que
cuando haya nuevos avances se podamos
volver a conversar mientras tanto
quisiera darle la bienvenida a nuestra
primera invitada de este cubrimiento
especial y ella es marta gonzález
analista política y especialista en
geopolítica también es periodista y
politóloga y nos acompaña desde madrid
de españa marta gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y comienzo
preguntándole russia hace pocas horas se
respondió que reaccionará con mucha
dureza como ya lo había dicho serguéi
lávrov a las sanciones que imponga la
unión europea en que podría consistir
esa dureza de la reacción de rusia
hola buenas tardes
bueno estamos creo que no se me ve bien
ahora perdone bueno la dureza de las
sanciones de la reacción de rusia va
lógicamente a depender de la reacción es
que si es unánime o no es unánime y que
sea más fuerte o menos fuerte por parte
de la otan y de la unión europea
parece ser que rusia no ha no ha tenido
en cuenta que la unión europea a partir
aparte de a pesar de la
de la diferencia de criterios a la hora
de establecer la relación que tiene cada
uno de los miembros con europa con con
rusia y va a tener una respuesta tan
contundente y tan asertiva en el sentido
de que las sanciones que ha prometido
dar a la
perdón
me oye bien sí sí sí le escucho perdone
cree es que no les escucho bien en el
sentido de que las canciones que la
unión europea parece que va a poner en
marcha si se ponen en marcha realmente
van a ser lo suficientemente eficaces
como para poner en grave riesgo el
régimen de vladimir putin en este
sentido sí me gustaría resaltar que
como apunte en la otra vez que tuve
ocasión de hablar en este mismo programa
hay una posición
de política interna y de política
externa que está condicionando de alguna
manera esta reacción tan extrema de
rusias en este sentido el presidente
putin solamente puede retirarse con lo
que eso implica de coste político a
nivel interno o puede seguir adelante y
en ese sentido hay que tener un poco de
calma porque él reacción que puede tener
el presidente es es en este momento
imprevisible y marta mientras que usted
y yo conversamos pues están sucediendo
muchas cosas por un lado el embajador
ucraniano en washington ofreció una
rueda de prensa a medios de comunicación
y declaró que fallecieron ya 40 soldados
y hay decenas de civiles también que
perecieron en medio de los
enfrentamientos por el ataque de rusia a
ucrania también estamos esperando más
adelante declaraciones del presidente
joe biden después de ser en un puente un
encuentro del grupo de los siete y
estamos esperando en horas de esta tarde
los anuncios de este nuevo paquete de
sanciones que se espera por parte de la
unión europea y en las que prometen ser
muy duros con rusia y alejar al país de
vladimir putin de la economía global así
que
quiero preguntarle mientras tanto por lo
que pasa en el terreno
también nos llegaron notificaciones de
que hay combates en la zona de la planta
nuclear de chernóbil y quería
preguntarle por este punto específico
cuál es la importancia de proteger este
punto de enfrentamientos que podría de
tomar los soldados rusos esta zona
fronteriza con ucrania
bueno lo que hemos visto en todo este
tiempo es que
el presidente putin tenía muy claro
desde un principio que toda toda esa
labor diplomática
estas acciones diplomáticas que están
venido produciendo en los últimos
tiempos han sido simplemente una
maniobra de distracción porque él tenía
muy claro que el último paso era
provocar la invasión de ucrania como se
está viendo en este momento está
apostando por tres líneas por un lado
está apostando por desactivar las o las
infraestructuras críticas tienes
la central nuclear es uno de los
de las infraestructuras críticas en este
sentido en este momento más más
vulnerables en el caso de que las tropas
rusas
rodearán la central nuclear estaríamos
hablando ya de palabras mayores porque
sería dar un paso un salto cualitativo a
las acciones armadas a las acciones
militares que está dispuesto a llevar a
cabo el presidente putin en un momento
de
tirar hacia hacia adelante y llegar
hacia hasta el final yo creo que en este
en este caso tanto la unión europea como
la otan no deberían permitir deberían
ser mucho más asertivos a la hora de
establecer cuáles son las líneas rojas
que europa la otan y eeuu van a tener
que establecer y hasta donde van a poder
y van a querer llegar para parar
y que el presidente putin pueda seguir
llegando
y avanzando en su camino de seguir
invadiendo rusia y ucrania perdón es
tremendamente
complicado y tremendamente difícil que
si el presidente putin
toma la decisión de utilizar armamento
nuclear o biológico la unión europea y
la otan no tomen una medida al respecto
con lo que la escalada de tensión
llegaría a un segundo nivel
mucho más complicado del que en
principio prevemos que pueda llegar a
pasar pues mientras que estamos hablando
de líneas rojas pues precisamente
quisiera que conversaremos acerca de lo
que está pasando con la crisis desatada
internacionalmente la invito para que
veamos nuestro siguiente reporte porque
la incursión militar de rusa en ucrania
pues se llegó a varias naciones entre
ellas los países bálticos que le piden a
la otan que inicien consultas para
activar el artículo 4 de la alianza con
el fin de tomar decisiones militares
cuando uno de los se siente amenazado
aunque ucrania no es parte del grupo
veamos
la novedad del tirón
mire ya tiene 23 años y es una sargento
española destinada en la misión de la
otan en letonia
su posición es táctica con su pelotón
entrena para disparar en primera línea
de fuego y para mí es un orgullo estar
aquí representando a españa además a la
otra y trabajar con humanidad con la que
ha estado trabajando estos dos meses
anteriores pues también es como un sueño
cumplido
como ustedes pero todo el grupo táctico
multinacional de batalla con base en
letonia está liderado por canadá y
albergan nueve nacionalidades distintas
el coronel sanders baggers es el
comandante de la brigada mecanizada
letona al cargo de la base
la misión se creó hace cinco años para
disuadir y defender es simple todo está
relacionado con la disuasión pero al
mismo tiempo si las cosas van mal es una
misión de defensa aquí
gordon
la lección rusa de crimea precipitó la
creación de tres batallones
internacionales en los países bálticos
que empezaron a operar en 2017
la situación del conflicto de ucranianos
llegó al punto de empezar a pensar en
cómo podemos defender nuestro país en
oro un campo cada movimiento que hace
putin en esta frontera de los bálticos
pone en alerta a toda la región la otan
ha reforzado el flanco oriental polonia
bulgaria también ha mandado efectivos
aéreos a estonia lituania y no se
descarta todavía un refuerzo mayor los
observadores cargamos posiciones del
objetivo así que ellos están
reconociendo los objetivos pasando la
información a los camiones calculando
los datos y mandan en sus datos a la
línea de disparo los adiestramientos en
la base de la otan de letonia son
continuos en este caso entrena en el
lanzamiento de proyectiles
you can't inhibidor training vamos a
continuar con nuestro entrenamiento
intensificaremos nuestra preparación
continuaremos compartiendo información
con nuestros socios y estaremos
preparados para apoyar a cualquier país
miembro de la otan vio ayer el nuevo
reality support and night del country la
otan aumentó su presupuesto desde que
estalló la guerra en el este de ucrania
y aunque sólo 10 países cumplen con la
aportación del 2% de su pib esta cifra
ha ido en aumento
nos trasladamos rápidamente hasta
washington con nuestro corresponsable
cristóbal vázquez para conversar sobre
las declaraciones que dio hace minutos
el representante ucraniano en la
embajada de washington cristóbal de
gracias y por favor que dijo el
representante
si dijo que ucrania va a salir
victoriosa de este conflicto le pidió a
todos sus aliados internaciones que por
favor tomen acciones severas en contra
de rusia también hizo un conteo
provisional del costo humano que hasta
ahora ha dejado esta invasión rusa en
ucrania dijo que de parte de ucrania se
contaban 40 soldados muertos en este
momento que varias decenas de ucranianos
estaban también heridos y algunos el
desaparecido dijo que por parte de la
defensa ucraniana hacia rusia
pues han derivado ya dos helicópteros
siete aviones de combate rusos derivados
también atrás a la defensa ucraniana y
pues ese fue el mensaje que ucrania va a
salir victoriosa y que le pide entonces
a la comunidad internacional que no
solamente pues te condene y que aplique
las sanciones sino que también mande
ayuda militar que incremente la ayuda
militar
para su defensa sobre todo en el caso
del espacio del espacio aéreo que mande
refuerzos precisamente en ese sentido
para pues
proteger y respaldar la respuesta
ucraniana frente a esta avanzada de
rusia hay de bens y hay que mencionar
también que el el primer el ministro de
relaciones exteriores ucraniano también
dijo que sin pelos en la lengua sin
diplomacia le pedía a todos los países
que consideren sacar a rusia del sistema
swift este es el sistema bancario
internacional que pues entonces tendría
efectos económicos bastante severos para
rusia porque pues no le permitiría
entonces a las instituciones financieras
rusas recibir los pagos de las
exportaciones de gas y del petróleo es
de resaltar también pues el comunicado
que sacan de tanto la casa blanca como
los miembros los líderes del g-7 tras
esta reunión donde dicen
contundentemente que trabajarán juntos
para defender la soberanía ucraniana y
el orden internacional
y diciendo además que vladimir putin
está del lado incorrecto de la historia
y que está posicionándose como una
amenaza al orden mundial cristóbal y
quiero seguir por esa línea porque
también estamos esperando más adelante
declaraciones del presidente de eeuu joe
biden tras su encuentro con los líderes
del g-7 usted tiene alguna previsión que
podríamos esperar de palabras del
presidente estadounidense teniendo en
cuenta que durante toda esta jornada los
líderes ucranianos y los embajadores en
diferentes países han hecho llamados
para recibir un apoyo más concreto de
parte del gobierno estadounidense
exactamente ya voló vil selenski
presidente de ucrania lo decía a días
anteriores decía que no basta
simplemente con que los países condenen
lo que está haciendo rusia sino que este
es el momento en el que se define y en
el que se muestra quiénes son
verdaderamente los aliados y los amigos
de ucrania no solamente al condenarlos
sino con sanciones mucho más severas
entre estas sanciones está precisamente
este este este tema del swift de sacar a
rusia del sistema bancario internacional
esto tendría graves efectos obviamente
para rusia pero también para eeuu y
alemania que serían uno de los países
más afectados pero en este discurso que
inicialmente se iba a dar a las doce y
media de la tarde hora de washington
aquí en la casa blanca se aplaza unos
minutos precisamente pues de cara a
todas las reuniones que ha tenido yo
bailén con su consejo de seguridad con
otros asesores de inteligencia de el
departamento de estado del departamento
de defensa que hacen parte de este
consejo nacional de seguridad
y obviamente a esta avanzada rusia y
tratando de recibir la mayor cantidad de
inteligencia la mayor cantidad de
información para responder
contundentemente a estas con estas
sanciones yo bailén ha dicho obviamente
que tras la escalada entre más sea el
avance de rusia más dura será la
respuesta de parte de eeuu una respuesta
que le advirtió el presidente yo bailé a
los estadounidenses tendrá un costo
local un costo para los estadounidenses
no solamente a la hora por ejemplo de
echar gasolina en las estaciones de
gasolina sino también pues que tendrá un
efecto en la inflación un tema que
preocupa mucho a los estadounidenses
porque la inflación pues ha sido
superior al 7% en el último mes y eso
pues ha repercutido mucho en el bolsillo
y en el día a día de los estadounidenses
así que pues sí yo bailén dijo esto
tendrá un efecto grande para los
estadounidenses pero que hará todo lo
posible todo lo que está en sus manos
todo lo que está en su caja de
herramientas
alianzas con la empresa privada
precisamente para que el costo de estas
sanciones y estas nuevas sanciones que
anunciará más cerca de la una y media de
la tarde hora de washington el
presidente yo bailen tengan el menor
efecto posible que en los ciudadanos
estadounidenses
y ahora volveremos más adelante para el
análisis de después de escuchar las
palabras del presidente joe biden del
otro lado en rusia en su más reciente
intervención el presidente de vladimir
putin aseguró que su país no tenía más
opciones que realizar la operación
militar especial dijo que los intentos
previos por cambiar la situación no
rindieron fruto por lo que el kremlin se
vio obligado a tomar esas medidas
asimismo dijo que rusia sigue siendo
parte de la economía global y que los
aliados no deberían tratar de sacarlos
del sistema económico escuchemos esto
pero que está ocurriendo ahora son
medidas forzadas no nos han dejado otra
forma de proceder o twitpic inácio y
previamente también escuchábamos las
declaraciones del primer ministro
británico o boris johnson quien ha hecho
fuertes anuncios ante el parlamento
dadas las últimas acciones rusas sobre
el territorio ucraniano escuchemos
me abra nuevos poderes para hacer blanco
de las financias rusas en adición a los
bancos que ya hemos sancionado hoy en
concierto con eeuu estamos imponiendo 1
congelamiento completo en los bienes de
rusia estos pues les permitirán excluir
completamente a los bancos rusos
del sistema financiero del reino unido-
por supuesto es uno de los mayores de
europa por eso putin
deberá enfrentar condenas en los ojos
del mundo y de la historia él nunca
podrá limpiar la sangre de ucrania de
sus manos y aunque el reino unido- y
nuestros aliados e intentaron cualquier
todos los caminos por la informaciã
hasta el momento final se me ha llegado
a concluir que putin siempre estuvo
determinado a atacar a su vecino
continuamos en nuestro cubrimiento
especiales después del ataque este
jueves de tropas rusas a ucrania una
incursión que está en curso y nosotros
seguimos atentos a los detalles y al
desarrollo de la situación internacional
y geopolítica vamos ahora a conversar
con andrés
analista internacional desde argentina
andrés gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente eeuu dice que el ataque ruso
puede ser potencialmente
sangriento usted qué opina
bueno evidentemente ya muestras de que
sangriento extensión que a veces las
afirmaciones que hacen algunas
administraciones son como ex post facto
no pero bueno lo importante es que
estamos frente a una situación de
confrontación bélica muy dramática con
repercusiones todos impredecibles en
términos regionales y yo me temo que
inclusive en términos globales lo que
estamos asistiendo si es que con un
cierto agrado de más allá de las
condenas y de las sanciones económicas a
un cierto grado de impotencia por parte
de las potencias occidentales por
estados unidos por la misma otan en el
sentido de cómo actuar para poder apoyar
a ucrania en esta situación clara
impresión de que no se encuentra una
salida adecuada o bueno sobre eso le
quería preguntar por qué eeuu ha
declarado de los diplomáticos de la casa
blanca que buscan formas de ayudar a
ucrania a defenderse a sí misma cuáles
serían esas formas sin realizar una
intervención bélica
pero seguramente asistencia en términos
de armamento asistencia en términos de
entrenamiento si hay una eventual
resistencia a asistencia financiera a un
gobierno que puede estar ahí o puede
estar en el exilio eso habrá que ver
cómo se desarrollan los acontecimientos
pero lo cierto es que
precediendo a todo esto hay una
afirmación del presidente barreda de que
después de afganistán no se van a
involucrar los eeuu en otra guerra
primer punto y segundo punto si bien es
cierto lo que acaba de comentar
de los costos que puede representar para
los estadounidenses
estos costos por el momento están
contabilizándose en términos económicos
fundamentalmente el impacto de la
inflación en el crecimiento de expresión
y el petróleo etcétera pero no se ha
planteado en ningún momento una
intervención
estadounidense de la otan o de los
países europeos en la situación nuclear
andrés servín e argentino desde santo
domingo y también sigue con nosotros o
marta gonzález analista política
especialista en geopolítica marta qué
tan factible es que rusia se ha retirado
del sistema swift
no lo veo factible porque no veo
unanimidad en este momento no solamente
entre los miembros de la unión europea
que muestran sus reticencias empezando
por alemania y siguiendo por francia
pero además sería desde mi punto de
vista aún una una resolución que no
tendría ningún efecto práctico para el
régimen de putin ni para evitar que el
régimen que putin siguiera adelante con
con esta escalada de tensión que ha
puesto que en realidad
ucrania solamente es un punto en el
iceberg de una cuestión que plantea gran
escala y es el cambio de la seguridad
regional en europa y tener una una
posición de liderazgo a nivel
internacional que rusia ha perdido
después de la guerra fría y esa
situación él está llevando a tomar
decisiones muy drásticas en el terreno
militar en europa pero también
involucrarse en otras zonas del planeta
donde está teniendo una posición muy
asertiva veremos en este momento si la
situación porque la intervención en
ucrania no va a ser la primera pueden
seguir los países del báltico veremos
que puede pasar en otras zonas donde hay
minorías rusas y donde hay problemas de
minorías como por ejemplo en moldavia en
la zona de transmitía y esto va a tener
repercusiones no solamente militares
económicas de seguridad internacional e
incluso puede tener repercusión en el
futuro de de la propia rusia
rápidamente un inciso para actualizar la
información a nuestros televidentes el
ministerio de defensa de rusia aseguró
en un comunicado que la primera jornada
de los ataques sobre ucrania fue un
éxito una noticia que está en desarrollo
y que vamos a analizar más adelante
entre tanto andrés se vuelvo con usted
pero esta vez para preguntarle por la
dependencia energética que es uno de los
grandes medios en este asunto y lo que
han pedido por ejemplo el ministro
británico gordon son y en lo que ha
insistido la jefa de la comisión
europea- úrsula van der leyen y es que
ya no dependa europa del suministro
energético
enviado desde el gobierno de moscú usted
opina que esto es factible cortar este
lazo y bueno aquí viene la suspensión
del proyecto del nord stream 2
y más allá del norte lindos a corto
plazo es muy difícil que europa cortes u
de tendencia
de la energía que proviene de rusia esto
no implica todo reciclaje y además
costos más altos para que lleve energía
de otros lados como está promoviendo
mismos eeuu o en el caso de otros países
como qatar yo creo que esto es un poco
parte de las condenas verbales que se
están emitiendo pero no creo que haga
haciendo expresión muy bien en mi colega
yo creo que en europa haya un consenso
claro con respecto a cuánto se puede
avanzar en romper las relaciones
económicas con funciones
mire andrés y entonces cómo van a ser
los países de occidente para cumplir su
promesa de proteger a los ciudadanos de
la subida de los precios a partir pues
de esta dependencia del combustible
bueno yo creo que ya se ha visto entre
otras cosas como algunos de los
indicadores económicos en estos días
entre otras cosas por ejemplo el
derrumbe de wall street y de otras
bolsas a raíz de la guerra que esto va a
tener efectos económicos muy graves para
las economías de occidente también ahora
entendamos que esto el trasfondo de esto
no es solamente lo que está pasando en
este momento en ucrania sino que tiene
que ver con una reconfiguración de las
relaciones de poder a nivel mundial en
donde rusia ha jugado su carta para
aparecer como un actor importante es
protagónico yo diría y en el mundo
occidental no termina de reaccionar
teniendo en cuenta que además hay otro
actor que está a la espera también de
contribuir a la reconfiguración de las
relaciones de poder mundial que es china
es decir estamos en una transición muy
compleja en donde esto es un episodio de
esa transición global que se está
produciendo pues muchísimas gracias
andrés gracias marta ella regreso con
ustedes el presidente joe biden emitió
en su cuenta de twitter hace segundos
una declaración ha dicho que el eje de
acuerdo a avanzar con un paquete
devastador de sanciones y de otras
medidas económicas para enfrentar a
rusia y a continuación veamos un poco
más desde el contexto que vive la región
del donbass desde el año 2014 allí se
ubican las zonas pro rusas de donges y
lugares
desde 2014 se autodenominan repúblicas
populares de done jet ski lugansk y con
apoyo ruso buscan mantenerse
independientes de ucrania en un
conflicto que ya se ha cobrado
aproximadamente 15 mil vidas
la república popular de done jets que
tiene más de 2 millones de habitantes la
de lugansk un millón y medio pero la
región conocida como el donbass se
extiende más allá de esta frontera
armada también llamada el cinturón de
óxido de ucrania se trata de un enclave
vital por su importancia minera e
industrial
rusia ha expedido unos 800 mil
pasaportes a ciudadanos de estas zonas
separatistas y reconoció este lunes su
independencia
creo que es necesario tomar una decisión
que ya estaba atrasada reconocer
inmediatamente la independencia y
soberanía de la república popular de
donges y la república popular de lugansk
pido a la asamblea federal de la
federación rusa a apoyar esta decisión y
ratificar los tratados de amistad y
asistencia mutua con ambas repúblicas no
comisión
ahora podrían convertirse en el
trampolín de vladimir putin en su
ofensiva militar sobre ucrania una
ofensiva militar que enfrenta una de las
principales potencias del mundo con una
república relativamente nueva el
presupuesto militar ucraniano supone
menos de un 10% del ruso russia tiene
cuatro veces más tropas y un equipo
terrestre marítimo y aéreo mucho más
extenso una amenaza difícil de ignorar
y sigo con nuestra invitada y analista
marta gonzález marta nadie celebra lo
que está pasando en este momento en
ucrania sin embargo quiero preguntarle
si existe una suerte de tormenta
perfecta por ejemplo para líderes como
boris johnson o como emanuel macrón
boris johnson o pues con todo el
escándalo del party que sea lentamente
quedado rezagado ante la importancia de
la crisis internacional y enmanuel
macrón que se enfrenta próximamente a
elecciones para las que por cierto
todavía no ha confirmado oficialmente su
candidatura y no se espera que lo haga
porque está concentrando sus energías
precisamente en esta crisis y esto
podría según dicen los medios franceses
general e incluso favorabilidad a la
hora de ser reelecto
bueno yo no me atrevo a especular sobre
cuáles son las reglas y
razones que un líder interno tiene un
líder fuera de mi país tiene para
decidir una política u otra respecto de
ucrania creo que no tienen margen de
maniobra estamos en una situación en un
contexto global de la unión europea en
la que las decisiones en este caso se
están tomando por consenso en el seno de
la otan y parece que hay un consenso
bastante
amplio y gran bretaña no forma parte de
la unión europea y bueno me parece
aventurado
decir que va a utilizar el presidente
macro en la situación de de ucrania para
beneficio personal pero
todo todo es posible
pues marta le agradezco su sinceridad y
por supuesto todo es posible y vamos a
propósito de eso hasta parís con nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz quien ha estado
con nosotros también es de toda la
mañana haciendo el cubrimiento y
contándonos las reacciones desde francia
natalia cuál es la posición en este
momento del gobierno galo frente a la
crisis y quiero pedirle que nos cuente
sobre las dificultades que están
viviendo en este momento ante la
imposibilidad de seguir evacuando a los
ciudadanos franceses que están en
ucrania por este aviso se podría decir
tardío esta petición de que salieran del
territorio
así es muy buenas tardes pues se hizo un
corto discurso se dirigió a los
franceses a comienzos de esta tarde en
el que dijo pues esto se trataba de un
acto de guerra que había que mantenerse
unidos y que esto iba a tener unas
consecuencias muy importantes
económicas y geopolíticas también y que
de todas maneras éste era un poco como
una especie de punto de giro que se
estaba viviendo no solamente en francia
sino sobre todo en europa digamos como
una especie de momento histórico y él
dijo pues que las sanciones la respuesta
de francia y de europa iba a estar pues
a la altura de pues de la agresión de la
agresión rusa y manuel marco ha tenido
una jornada bastante
densa bastante amplia el día de hoy
comenzó con esa llamada al presidente
volodymyr selenski luego tuvo ese
consejo de defensa en el que se
discutieron se planearon digamos cuáles
son las medidas que va a tomar francia y
las medidas también que iba a discutir a
discutir luego con los demás socios del
g7 también luego el consejo europeo
también en la reunión con la otan como
eran una jornada bastante complicada se
supieron se saben ahora nuevas cosas por
una parte un alma home va a hablar
mañana frente al parlamento francés es
muy posible que en ese momento pues él
dé a conocer y algunas de las medidas
son las medidas que se han discutido a
lo largo del día de hoy las medidas por
ejemplo a las que las decisiones a las
que se llegó ya con el g7 y también se
supo que va a recibir en el palacio del
elíseo a los dos ex presidentes nicolas
sarkozy y también alfonso o long en
cuanto a lo que usted me preguntaba
acerca de los franceses que se quedaron
en ucrania porque efectivamente pues no
pasaron más de 12 horas cuando pues ya
comenzó este este conflicto en pleno y
fue justamente 12 horas antes pues el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores
francés había pedido a sus a los
ciudadanos franceses que salieran de
ucrania como usted bien lo decía pues ya
no es imposible del espacio aéreo está
cerrado pero sí se creó aquí una una
célula de crisis
en el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores que está en total
comunicación todo el tiempo con la
embajada francesa en la ciudad de guía
tratando de ver cómo pueden brindarle el
apoyo a los a los ciudadanos franceses
que lo necesiten y en algún momento pues
podrían buscar cómo poderlos evacuar por
ahora lo que le han pedido a los
franceses que están en ese país es que
por una parte eviten todo tipo de viaje
hacia el este hacia el norte y sobre
todo pese a que permanezcan bien
resguardados muy complicado gracias a
natalia por la información y seguimos
haciendo la ronda de reacciones
internacionales de gobiernos y
ciudadanos esta vez se nos vamos a
dirigir hasta israel con el reporte de
nuestra corresponsal e deyanira gómez
muñoz sobre las recientes reacciones del
gobierno rechazando este ataque a
ucrania
en una muy breve declaración pero siendo
la primera oficial en la que se
interpela explícitamente a rusia el
ministro de exteriores de israel ya isla
condenó el ataque de rusia a
ucrania calificándolo de grave violación
al orden mundial al orden internacional
se trata de una de las declaraciones más
duras de israel hacia rusia desde la
guerra de georgia en 2008 pero por ahora
no se espera que vaya a ir más allá no
se espera que israel vaya a estar más
contundente contra el presidente ruso
vladimir putin y esto se debe a una
razón estratégica y es que podríamos
decir que a israel no le conviene
enfadar lo o decepcionar lo ya que rusia
además de tener presencia militar
controla parcialmente el espacio aéreo
de siria permitiendo como hemos visto
esa semana que israel incursiones o
ataques y objetivos iraníes en este país
con quien comparte fronteras en el norte
pero además esta relación estratégica
conveniente podemos decir que desde los
años 2000 rusia e israel han mantenido
unas buenas relaciones diplomáticas
siendo obviamente israel el único país
parcialmente ruso fono fuera de los
antiguos estados soviéticos
con toda esta relación al ministro de
exteriores- lápiz nos ha olvidado del
pueblo de ucrania pero sobre todo ha
tendido la mano ha recordado a las
comunidades judías e israelíes en este
país a las primeras que se cifran en
unos 200.000 judíos en ucrania les ha
atendido acogida mientras que a las
segundas que son entre 6.000 y 8.000
israelíes en ucrania les ha pedido que
por favor acudan lo antes posible por
vía terrestre a las fronteras del oeste
en este sentido a través del ministerio
de exterior israelí ha desplegado
personal oficial para poder ayudar a la
evacuación de todas estas personas que
lo quieran entre los cruces de ucrania y
los cinco países limítrofes al oeste
a lo largo de europa la opinión pública
rechaza el ataque a ucrania en españa'
ciudadanos ucranianos protestaron frente
a la embajada rusa de madrid al mismo
tiempo fue escenario de protestas en
berlín y también a otras varias ciudades
alemanas al tiempo que el embajador
ucraniano en esa nación pidió armas
defensivas para que quien se pueda
responder a moscú también hubo protestas
en roma italia y en parís es cientos se
apostaron frente a la embajada rusa de
francia turquía también fue uno de los
lugares donde se vivió el rechazo vamos
precisamente hacia estambul con nuestro
corresponsal de adrià rocha que tiene
los detalles adrià en que quedaron estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas en contra del
ataque a ucrania
pues de momento no son muchos los
ciudadanos turcos que se están
manifestando por esta gran precisamente
porque turquía tiene un papel muy
difícil en este conflicto que ha
empezado hoy entre en la invasión rusa
de toda ucrania porque es muy difícil
papel de rosa porque de zurda puede la
protegía porque turquía tiene muy buenas
relaciones con los dos países ya ha
intentado desde el primer momento que
empezaron las centrales a principios de
este mismo año intentar mediar en tres
de lenski y putin con pierre con que al
presente turco recep tayyp erdogán tiene
una excelente relación según el mismo y
asegura en muchas ocasiones que son
amigos e incluso a vettel ha llamado a
mi hermano a ruso además turquía tiene
muchísimo que perder en esta guerra
aún no participar por el hecho de estar
muy vinculadas economía y sociedades con
las sociedades de economía rusa y
ucraniana por ejemplo a turquía
conseguir todo su cereal de datos de
jose o crank ya tus dos turistas máxima
mente bien en the tourist de de rusia y
ucrania y sobre todo turquía cuando los
dos estrechos que cierran el mar el mar
que comparten rusia y ucrania de hecho
hoy mismo el gobierno ucraniano ha
pedido a turquía que cierre estas dos
estrechas según la convención de monroe
turquía puede cerrar los derechos de los
dardanelos del bósforo por donde está
está muy sin embargo no lo ha hecho
turquía y parece ser que no lo va a
hacer por un gran motivo y es que
turquía no quiere enfadar a rusia con
quien comparte además escenario bélico
en siria y un y turquía teme que un
enfado de rusia un a un abundante
agoniza miento de rusia en cuatro de
turquía podría provocar que la guerra
siria después de lograr se caliente y
eso puede llevar muchos millones
millones de refugiados que esperan en la
frontera con turquía que puedan intentar
entrar en el país sanatorio y crear una
nueva crisis que ahora mismo a turquía
con una crisis económica muy punzante no
le apetece fruta para nada minería se me
adelantó contando pues precisamente esta
posición estratégica y difícil que tiene
turquía en esta semana también hemos
informado desde france24 y con su ayuda
que turquía se ofreció para mediar en
esta crisis entre rusia y ucrania
una solicitud o una propuesta que hasta
ahora pues no ha sido tomada en cuenta
por el kremlin en que quedaron esos
esfuerzos usted cree que hay cabida ya
ha entrado en un conflicto bélico para
dar un retroceso nuevamente a la vida
diplomática
pues han quedado casi en papel mojado
tienes que encontrar los tres en el
mismo sitio el esquí se mostró muy
dispuesto a hacerlo pero putin siempre
desechó esos contactos diciendo que
estaban de acuerdo nuestros contactos
pero que siempre tenían que ucrania
tenía que desarmarse primero tenía que
aceptar las condiciones que imponía su
sexo evidentemente no ha ocurrido como
podemos comprobar todos ahora mismo y la
posición de román en este papel mediador
ha quedado muy dañada sin embargo sí que
voy el presidente turco ha hablado por
primera vez después de esta invasión y
después del reconocimiento de las
repúblicas de donettes gilligan's y ha
dicho que turquía no puede aceptar una
invasión como la que está realizando
turquía rusia su aliado sin embargo
turquía se muestra muy contraria a
sancionar a rusia precisamente por lo
comentamos por el miedo que tiene
turquía de antagonizar a rusia y por lo
tanto se espera que el papel de turco de
turquía ahora mismo sea de intentar
mediar entre un gran rusia porque parece
que eso es tarde pero si entre occidente
y rusia para intentar encontrar un papel
o una solución a ese conflicto
diplomático que se creará a partir de
ahora entre oxiden y rusia- encontraron
una solución un poco más suave a lo que
quiere probablemente encontrar occidente
precisamente turquía está bastante
enfadada en que estas informaciones que
están teniendo lugar en el seno de
muchos países europeos como estábamos
comentando anteriormente turquía no está
invitada y el motivo es precisamente
éste turquía no quiere a que rusia se
vea muy dañado porque esto dañaría
muchísimo al propio país odonkor pues
adrián le agradesco por su intervención
y por el análisis que nos entrega así
vamos a dar finalización a esta ronda de
nuestros corresponsables alrededor de
todo el mundo con las reacciones
internacionales sobre este ataque de
rusia sobre ucrania
estamos en cubrimiento especial en
france 24 que desde con nosotros pequeña
pausa y ya volvemos con más
[Música]
la información al momento en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
hola
regresamos con nuestro cubrimiento de
especiales de francia 24 sobre el ataque
de rusia y ucrania al inicio de la
jornada de las tropas llegaron desde
rusia y belarús y aterrizaron en las
costas de los mares en negro y de azul
desde entonces hay enfrentamientos entre
las fuerzas ucranianas y rusas a lo
largo de la mayor parte de la frontera
incluyendo la zona de chernóbil en
varias ciudades del país se han
reportado decenas de cientos de misiles
y el presidente de volodymyr excellence
que instó a los ciudadanos a defender el
territorio asimismo indicó que se
proveerán armas a quienes puedan a
manejarlas por su parte el alcalde de
kiev también ordenó un toque de queda en
la ciudad y desde no al menos o cuatro
estaciones del metro de kiev es como
refugios antimisiles dado el caso se
reportaron también en la destrucción es
de 40 instalaciones en militares hay al
menos 40 soldados ucranianos fallecidos
y algunos diplomáticos hablan de decenas
de civiles que también habrían podido
perecer o están desaparecidos en medio
de los enfrentamientos
ucrania mantiene desde madrugada su
espacio aéreo cerrado así como sus
puertos mientras que miles de personas
intentan evacuar en automóvil de algunas
ciudades principales del país esta es
una noticia en desarrollo y continuamos
en el cubrimiento especiales de france
24 ininterrumpido desde las 10 de la
noche de anoche con todos los
acontecimientos que se desarrollan vamos
a continuar esta no es la primera vez
que moscú hace reconocimientos
separatistas regiones del mundo el
moldavia y georgia entre otros también
se han beneficiado en el pasado del
reconocimiento de su independencia por
parte del kremlin veamos la historia
es hora de tomar una decisión que llega
con retraso de reconocer inmediatamente
la independencia y la soberanía de las
repúblicas populares de dónetsk y lugar
cleries publicó el anuncio de vladimir
putin no es el primero de este tipo es
la tercera vez que rusia reconoce
oficialmente la independencia de un
territorio que hacía parte de las 15
repúblicas de la antigua unión soviética
territorios nacidos del conflicto con el
poder central y reconocido solo por muy
pocos países entre ellos rusia
este es el caso de osetia del sur
para la comunidad internacional es parte
de georgia
pero la republica tiene fronteras un
presidente una bandera y sus propias
instituciones en 1992 la región se
declaró independiente tras un referendo
en 2008 estalló una guerra de cinco días
con georgia rusia intervino y se llegó a
un acuerdo de paz moscú reconoció
entonces la independencia de osetia del
sur
para la alegría de sus habitantes
a asia es otra parte de georgia
respaldada por el kremlin el territorio
de ocho mil seiscientos kilómetros
cuadrados entre el cáucaso y el mar
negro también proclamó su independencia
en un referendo en
1999 que fue considerado ilegal por las
naciones unidas pero el 26 de agosto de
2008 el mismo día en que reconoció a
osetia del sur
moscú también declaró la independencia
de abjasia otra zona progresa entre
moldavia y ucrania transitoria en 1992
la región declaró su independencia esta
vez rusia no la respaldó al menos no
oficialmente pero su política y economía
están muy influenciadas por moscú quien
también proporciona apoyo militar
protegiendo el territorio con al menos
1000 soldados
30 años después de la caída de la unión
soviética esta franja de europa del este
sigue siendo el patio trasero de moscú
y después de que el presidente ruso
vladimir putin anunciara una
intervención militar especial y que
dijera que su objetivo era
desmilitarizar y eliminar la amenaza
neonazi en ucrania según sus propias
palabras la unión europea encabezó la
condena internacional contra las
acciones de moscú sus líderes celebran
una cumbre de emergencia en bruselas con
el jefe del bloque prometiendo las
sanciones más duras hasta el momento
veamos las reacciones internacionales
una respuesta rápida y concertada de los
líderes mundiales después de que rusia
lanzará la tan temida ofensiva contra
ucrania la unión europea anunció nuevas
sanciones el jueves que apuntarán a los
activos de rusia en el bloque y a
suprimir la capacidad del kremlin para
financiar una guerra a gran escala
europea y unión la unión europea
responderá en los términos más enérgicos
posibles y dejar el paquete de sanciones
más severo que jamás hayamos
implementado simplemente en una
declaración televisada alemania anunció
que se coordinará con la unión europea
la otan y el g7 enfatizando la flagrante
violación del derecho internacional por
parte de rusia putin
putin está trayendo sufrimiento y
destrucción a sus vecinos violando la
soberanía y las fronteras de ucrania
está poniendo en peligro innumerables
vidas inocentes en ucrania
el presidente francés emmanuel macro le
anunció fuertes sanciones a rusia y
sonsón por las sanciones aplicadas a
rusia estarán al final al mismo nivel
que la agresión de la que es culpable
planos militar y económico boris johnson
también reaccionó hoy en concierto con
nuestros aliados acordaremos un paquete
masivo de sanciones económicas diseñadas
a tiempo para hacer tambalear a la
economía rusa alborch mejor ni más allá
de la unión europea israel condenó las
acciones rusas y dijo estar preparado
para ofrecer ayuda humanitaria para los
ciudadanos ucranianos el presidente
estadounidense joe biden prometió que
rusia rendirá cuentas por un ataque
provocado e injustificado mientras que
corea del sur y australia se encuentran
entre los últimos aliados en unirse a
los esfuerzos de sanciones
internacionales contra moscú
china no ha llegado a describir el
evento como una invasión pero ha dicho
que está observando de cerca la
situación mientras pide moderación a las
partes mientras tanto semanas de intensa
diplomacia la primera ronda de sanciones
occidentales contra rusia hasta ahora no
han logrado disuadir a putin quien ha
advertido de consecuencias sin
precedentes para los países que intenten
inmiscuirse en sus asuntos
siguen las reacciones de occidente vamos
en directo con las declaraciones del
líder canadiense ellos tiene todo
escuchamos en nuestro respaldo a la
soberanía de ucrania
y somos solidarios con el pueblo iraní
con su derecho a decidir su propio
futuro
en un estado libre y democrático
este martes después de que el presidente
putten reconociera la
supuesta independencia de dónetsk y
logan's canadá anunció una serie inicial
de sanciones concertadas y sanciones
buscan a las personas responsables
presiones y negras de rusia así como
a los bancos rusos respaldados por
estados también hemos prohibido que los
canadienses compren
deuda soberana rusa se les prohibirá
participar en cualquier tipo de
transacción financiera con los llamados
estados independientes de dónetsk y los
hanes
también anunciamos el despliegue de
460 fuerzas adicionales tropas
adicionales para respaldar
la operación
de la otan y bueno favorecer la paz y la
seguridad ante este ataque militar e
irresponsable nos ha obligado a imponer
sanciones mucho más severas estas
sanciones harán blanco en 58 individuos
y entidades incluyendo miembros de la
élite rusa y sus miembros y menos de sus
familias así como el grupo wagner y
otros bancos importantes rusos también
sancionaremos a los miembros del consejo
de seguridad ruso incluyendo al ministro
de defensa y al ministro de finanzas
el ministro de justicia
sumado a eso y es efectivo
inmediatamente estamos
negando todos los permisos de
exportación de rusia y cancelando los
permisos existentes estas sanciones
tienen gran alcance impondrán costos
severos en élites cómplices rusas y
limitará la capacidad presiente putin de
seguir patrocinando
esta invasión injustificada
ataque militar de rusia estamos
imponiendo sanciones mucho más severas
estas sanciones
son de un alcance mucho más amplio
traerán
acciones mucho mayores para los miembros
de la élite rusa y prevendrán que el
presidente putin para financiar este
ataque injustificado y quiero ser muy
claro el ataque de rusia en contra de
ucrania también es un ataque en contra
de la democracia
el estado de derecho y la libertad
repito el ataque solo que también es un
ataque sobre la democracia
la ley internacional del estado de
derecho los derechos humanos y sobre la
libertad
las acciones de rusia
son completamente opuestas a los
principios democráticos
muchas generaciones de canadienses han
luchado por defender
demócratas y los demócratas en todas
partes deben reunirse para defender
estos principios
estar en contra del auto de la autoridad
debemos rusia de hacer todas las
autoridades todas las acciones militares
en contra de ucrania y retirar todas las
puertas a los presos militares de la
región la integridad territorial de
ucrania debe ser respetar el pueblo
ucraniano como cualquier pueblo debe ser
libre de determinar su propio futuro
quiero dejar esto muy claro es nuestro
inconveniente en nuestro tema no es con
el pueblo de rusia sino con el
presidente putin y con el liderazgo ruso
que ha permitido y respaldado
esta invasión de ucrania
la verdad es que rusia ha violado la
soberanía de ucrania por años en 2014
ilegalmente anexo los electores del
crimen y desde entonces nunca se ha
detenido nunca ha detenido a herirla
nunca ha impedido hoy el presidente
putin abrió un nuevo capítulo oscuro de
esta historia al lanzar
una invasión bastante amplio bien son
momentos preocupantes para internacional
y para las personas en todas partes que
se preocupan por la libertad y por la
democracia aunque los ojos del mundo
observarán los líderes no podemos perder
la vista del costo humano desde
conflicto la gente inocente incluyendo
niños ahora están enfrentando violencia
y caos
en estos momentos tan oscuros del
mensaje de canadá al pueblo de ucrania
es esto ustedes no están solos
nosotros estamos del lado de ustedes
los canadienses y los precios recientes
permanecen premiando
su seguridad es nuestra prioridad
también queremos asegurar de que ustedes
llegarán al sitio seguro hemos acordado
pasos seguros en las fronteras con
eslovaquia hungría rumanía y moldavia
creemos estamos pidiendo documentos de
viaje para los canadienses los
residentes permanentes y sus miembros
familiares también estamos priorizando
aplicaciones migratorias para los
ucranianos que quieren venir a canadá y
para asegurar que podemos servir la
gente tan pronto como sea posible hoy
estamos lanzando una nueva línea
telefónica dedicada para cualquiera que
esté en ese país en otro país
que tenga dudas relacionadas con
migración ucrania
a los canadienses a los residentes
permanentes en ucrania su seguridad
son nuestra prioridad es nuestra
prioridad también queremos asegurarnos
de que ustedes pueden llegar a un sitio
seguro hemos acordado paso seguro para
que ustedes y para sus familias en las
mujeres terrestres de polonia eslovaquia
hungría rumania y moldova también
estamos emitiendo documentos de viaje
para los ghaneses afectados para
residentes permanentes y sus familiares
inmediatos también estamos priorizando
las aplicaciones migratorias en los
submarinos que quieran venir a canadá y
para asegurarnos de servir a la gente
tan pronto como sea posible hoy estamos
lanzando una nueva línea telefónica
dedicada para cualquier que en este país
o en otro que tenga alguna pregunta
urgente sobre la migración ucraniana
anoche hablé con los ingredientes en el
congreso cliente y creo ingrediente
hable dije que el presidente putin ha
subestimado la fortaleza y la unidad de
los aliados democráticos y de los socios
y que él ha subestimado a la fortaleza y
la determinación del pueblo ucraniano
estas son cualidades de los ucranianos
canadienses también ustedes han ayudado
a construir ese país ustedes están
orgullosos de su cultura de su herencia
y ustedes nunca se rinden y de nosotros
tampoco nos rendiremos nuestro respaldo
por ucrania por la democracia y por los
derechos humanos siguen siendo los
mismos igual de fuertes muchas gracias
ahora le voy a dar la palabra a la
primera ministra delegada chrystia
freeland
estamos en directo en france 24 haciendo
todo el cubrimiento de la situación que
se desarrolla a nivel internacional
después del ataque ruso sobre ucrania
escuchábamos al primer ministro
canadiense josh en trudeau quien anunció
sanciones más fuertes sobre ucrania las
acciones de rusia dijo violan los
principios de la democracia y la
integridad territorial de ucrania debe
ser respetada alineándose con los otros
líderes de occidente que hasta ahora han
hecho declaraciones mientras tanto ya
hay previsiones de las nuevas sanciones
que podría imponer eeuu y que podrían
ser anunciados en minutos por el
presidente joe biden incluyendo nuevas
sanciones
personalmente contra el presidente
vladimir putin
entretanto también hay más noticias
desde ucrania la presidencia dijo que
las tropas rusas ya tomaron las
centrales de chernóbil según dijeron los
diplomáticos ucranianos lo cual le sería
muy conflictivo dado que es la unión con
belarús y un punto estratégico dentro de
este conflicto bélico pero ahora vamos a
más ampliaciones desde bruselas con
nuestra corresponsal herrera este
estamos esperando los resultados o las
sanciones que puedan darse como
conclusión de una nueva reunión de
emergencia de los diplomáticos europeos
cuáles son las previsiones de estas
nuevas sanciones que han prometido ser
las más duras hasta el momento
hola buenas tardes sí en efecto los
líderes europeos se reúnen ahora de
urgencia aquí en la capital comunitaria
para abordar este nuevo paquete de
sanciones es una reunión de emergencia
convocada ayer justo horas antes de que
vladimir putin decidiera invadir ucrania
en cualquier caso hoy las sanciones han
advertido van a ser muy dolorosas y van
a dañar aún más a la economía rusa según
fuentes diplomáticas se quiere dañar a
sectores estratégicos de rusia como por
ejemplo el sector bancario se quiere
bloquear el acceso al mercado europeo
también habrá sanciones en cuestiones
energéticas aún hay que ver aún así
durante toda exclusión que se prevé que
va a ser muy larga y que va a durar toda
la noche también se tendrá que decidir
cuál lejos quieren llegar los líderes
europeos porque hay algunas divisiones
no a todos los países europeos les
afecta de la misma forma ya que algunos
tienen relaciones más estrechas
económicas como en rusia así que las
divisiones se pueden palpar aún así se
espera que los líderes europeos
finalmente puedan
de forma conjunta y unida en cualquier
caso la unión europea insiste en que
estas estas sanciones serán muy fuertes
y en la reunión de hoy además hablará ya
de un tercer paquete de sanciones porque
recordemos hace tan solo dos días ya se
aprobó un primer paquete ahora que se
está preparando un segundo y aún así en
esta reunión ya se hablará de unas
terceras sanciones que sean aún más
duras dependiendo de la escalada de la
tensión además también se abordará la
situación de la ayuda humanitaria a
ucrania a las personas desplazadas
dentro del país pero también al recibir
refugiados provenientes de la
provenientes de ucrania hacia la unión
europea países como polonia y han dicho
que tendrán sus fronteras abiertas
y también quería preguntarle sobre estas
a de sanciones están anunciadas por la
unión europea
usted cree desde su experiencia
cubriendo bruselas tantos años que
realmente habrá efectos fuertes sobre la
economía rusa que de repente si es
suficiente de esto para frenar la acción
bélica de rusia sobre ucrania
bueno lo que nos ha demostrado este
conflicto es que lamentablemente
vladimir putin es totalmente
impredecible a pesar de que habían
avisado a los países bálticos los países
del este de la otan y también eeuu de
que podría haber una guerra a escala sí
es cierto que ha creado un poco y ha
sido algo improcedente porque si bien ha
habido conflictos en crimea también no
ha sido de la misma forma por lo tanto
en la unión europea cree que estas
sanciones van a ser muy duras aunque
algunos analistas aseguran que estas
sanciones podrían tener un efecto a
largo plazo luego también hay otro
problema que es que la unión europea la
gran mayoría de países europeos dependen
mucho del gas ruso aquí el invierno aún
sigue siendo duro y por lo tanto se teme
que rusia cierre el grifo del gas eso
podría afectar a muchos países pero
entre ellos los países que se encuentran
en el centro de europa como bélgica
alemania pero también del norte por lo
tanto afecta mucho cómo hay que calibrar
qué tipo de sanciones porque si van
mucho más allá temen cuál puede ser la
respuesta furibunda de rusia sin embargo
la unión europea asegura que las
sanciones pueden ser muy fuertes
sí que es cierto que el primer paquete
de sanciones primero ha cerrado el grifo
a rusia para que pueda entrar en los
mercados europeos pero hay que tener en
cuenta rusia es un país poco endeudado
así que hay que ver hasta qué punto esto
puede afectar veremos este segundo
paquete de sanciones pero se afectan al
sector bancario ya los oligarcas por
ejemplo esto podría afectar mucho y muy
seriamente también hay que ver si puede
afectar al sistema swift de momento
según algunas fuentes consultadas de
momento se quiere esperar al tercer
paquete de sanciones pero de ser así
esto sí que podría dañar seriamente a
rusia este le agradezco y de bruselas
vamos a pasar hasta los países bajos con
nuestra corresponsable el mar y ángulo
almería buen día para ustedes y quiero
comenzar a preguntar no lee sobre las
medidas solicitadas por el gobierno
neerlandés contra rusia cuáles son los
efectos económicos que ya se ven en la
jornada de hoy sabemos que hay un
incremento del 40% en el precio del gas
y además en háblenos sobre este tema del
envío de municiones a ucrania
buenas tardes angela sí desde ya se
están sintiendo los efectos en el
territorio and air land es a causa del
inicio de estas operaciones militares
rusas en territorio ucraniano
notablemente se empezó a sentir en esta
jornada con el incremento como lo dices
del 40 por ciento en el valor del gas y
por primera vez en los últimos años
aunque venía al alza el precio de la
gasolina del litro de gasolina en
territorio de hernández superó la
barrera de los
2,2 euros con 20 centavos esta tarde se
llevó a cabo en la haya una reunión del
gobierno neerlandés encabeza el primer
ministro más router con su gabinete de
gobierno en la cual tras la cual
decidieron pedir sanciones máximas por
el hecho que consideran como una
agresión sin precedentes e
injustificables algo que vale la pena
aclarar es que países bajo sería uno de
los territorios del norte de europa más
afectados con esta crisis energética que
éste desata a raíz de estos ataques
debido a que recordemos que rusia es el
principal distribuidor de gas tanto para
el este como para el norte de europa
eso se puede ver notablemente en el alza
decrete por otra parte también hay que
tener en cuenta que el gobierno de
ajuste indicó que si bien al paquete de
medidas que nos indicaba la corresponsal
de bélgica que se llevará a cabo en
contra de rusia también se unen
canciones unilaterales que en el caso
del gobierno de rute van a ser
estudiadas a partir del día de mañana en
maría gracias a usted la tengo que parar
un momento porque está hablando el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres vamos a escuchar
sabemos cómo funcionan las guerras
garcía y cada vez los muertos hemos
visto imágenes de miedo angustia y
terror en cada rincón de ucrania
y cada día personas inocentes son los
que pagan el precio más alto por eso es
que las naciones unidas están escalando
y aumentando sus operaciones
humanitarias en y alrededor de la
ucrania anunció que estamos entregando
20 millones de dólares del fondo de
respuestas urgentes para tus hacer
presencia estamos comprometidos de
permanecer y entregar ayuda para
respaldar ucrania en su momento de mayor
necesidad
el equipo de las naciones unidos está
trabajando en ambos lados de la línea de
contacto siempre guiados por principios
humanitarios como la imparcialidad
transparencia independencia humanidad
estamos proveyendo ayuda para salvar
vidas de gente que lo necesita sin
importar dónde o quiénes sean
la protección de civiles
debe ser la prioridad número uno
la ley internacional y humanitaria debe
ser sostenida
las decisiones de los próximos días
darán forma a nuestro mundo
y afectarán directamente la vida de
millones y millones de personas
alineados con la carta
no es muy tarde para salvar a estas
generaciones
de la de la carga de la guerra
necesitamos paz muchas gracias
en las declaraciones del secretario
general de la onu antonio guterres y
después de esa breve pausa pues vamos a
regresar a los países bajos con el mar y
ángulo el mar y a usted estaba
terminando su intervención
y quiero sumarle mi segunda pregunta
cómo podría ser países bajos o un agente
estratégico para paliar un poco la
crisis energética que se le viene encima
a europa con este conflicto con rusia
en este momento países bajos se
encuentran en una encrucijada
diplomática notable ya que las
relaciones si bien no eran malas venían
fuertemente deterioradas desde el año
2014 cuando algunos sospechosos rusos
derribaron el avión de malasia airlines
en el que murieron 298 personas de las
cuales 196 grand slam de esas en el caso
puntual de la crisis energética hola
países bajos también llamado lambda se
vería abocado a recurrir a puntos de
extracción que habían sido clausurados
por temas medioambientales y por sismos
y deterioro de la calidad de vida de los
residentes cercanos lo cual el zoom
representaría un desglose de operaciones
que estaban ya canceladas desde hace
varios años hay algo que quiero acotar y
es importante porque países bajo va a
jugar un papel crucial en medio de este
conflicto en materia de municiones y en
materia de traslado de materiales ya que
cuenta con rotterdam que es la ciudad
portuaria más grande el puerto más
grande e importante de europa por el
cual se espera que próximos días ingrese
el material militar que será enviado por
el gobierno de jowhar den directamente
desde estados unidos para respaldar a
ucrania en este
pues el maría le agradezco por la
actualización de la situación y por
darnos un poco más del panorama europeo
que se vive en este momento entretanto
la situación en las calles de kiev ya
evidencia la incertidumbre que trae la
intervención rusa al país muchos
ciudadanos están huyendo del territorio
al tiempo que se reportan bombardeos en
varias regiones veamos
el sonido de explosiones lejanas resuena
en el centro de kiev
a medida que amanece las sirenas
antiaéreas de la capital ucraniana
sustituyen los estallidos
mientras rusia inicia su ofensiva
militar en ucrania los ciudadanos de
quien se apresuran a salir de la ciudad
ya sea por carretera o por tren
porque vas al metro porque la federación
rusa empieza una guerra en ucrania
entonces qué quieres hacer
salvar nuestras vidas
una de las primeras ciudades afectadas
es jarkko cerca de la frontera rusa el
sonido de los bombardeos resuena está
bien entrada la mañana
06 new hoy he tenido el peor amanecer de
mi vida a las 5 de la mañana me he
despertado y he oído una serie de
disparos he salido corriendo al balcón y
me dado cuenta de que no eran fuegos
artificiales eran explosiones de humo en
el horizonte del andén a 40 kilómetros
de distancia en su web el humo sale de
un aeropuerto militar alcanzado por los
proyectiles en la ciudad portuaria de
mariupol a menos de 20 kilómetros de las
trincheras más cercanas en la región
oriental del donbass la acumulación de
tropas es difícil de ignorar los
residentes hacen cola en un cajero
automático mientras se empieza a sentir
la prisa por abandonar lo que pronto
será una zona de guerra
ángela gómez en directo para ustedes
transmitiendo desde francia 24 con el
análisis y el cubrimiento el seguimiento
después de los ataques reportados este
jueves por parte de rusia hacia ucrania
y vamos a continuar con el análisis de
la mano de marta gonzález en nuestra
analista política especialista en
geopolítica de nacionalidad española y
con andrés servín analista internacional
e también de nacionalidad argentina y
quiero hacer una pregunta para ambos que
seguramente es lo que muchos de nuestros
televidentes se cuestionan en este
momento porque la comunidad
internacional en este punto cuando ya
hay una intervención bélica rusa no se
compromete con entrar con tropas a
ucrania y se mantiene evidentemente en
el terreno de las sanciones marta
comienzo con usted
bueno porque realmente en europa tenemos
una concepción de que la democracia en
los derechos humanos se tienen que
respetar y se tienen que cuidar y se
tienen que garantizar pero cuando llega
la hora de la verdad y cuando llega la
hora en la que un actor mucho más fuerte
que con capacidad militar y sobre todo
con voluntad para poner sobre la mesa
una capacidad militar de la que europa
todavía no es consciente ni quiere pues
estamos en una situación en la que no
podemos garantizar los derechos humanos
si cuando hay una agresión militar y con
botas' en europa no estamos dispuestos a
poner cadáveres sobre la mesa es
una triste realidad
andrés su opinión
en mi opinión primero empiezan a una
pregunta cuál comunidad internacional de
qué estamos hablando estamos hablando de
los países occidentales más eeuu mas
eventualmente canadá por lo que hemos
visto en todos los informes que han
presentado ustedes algunos países que
tienen posiciones distintas o en todo
caso con matices distintos y nadie se ha
preguntado con más allá de china qué es
lo que pasa con todo el conjunto de
países euro asiáticos hay un acuerdo
militar en la organización del tratado
de seguridad colectiva entre rusia y
cuatro ex repúblicas soviéticas habían
escuchado alguna expresión de eso hay
una organización de cooperación de
shanghai que aglutina a la mayor parte
de los países de asia central a china y
a rusia en china rusia fueron los
promotores de esta organización también
ha escuchado alguna opinión al respecto
por lo visto cuando llegamos al momento
de la discusión sobre las posibles
condenas y sanciones bueno en el ámbito
multilateral
esto no termina de expresarse con
claridad o se mantiene en posiciones
aparentemente neutrales pero la gran
pregunta es que estamos en un proceso de
reordenamiento del sistema internacional
y de este proceso de alrededor
y evidentemente los actores
tradicionales bueno tienen un poder
todavía decisivo pero también se
presentan con mucha cautela cuáles son
las decisiones que van a tomar frente a
una situación tan crítica como la que se
está viviendo en ucrania y esto hay que
tenerlo en cuenta porque a la hora de la
verdad nos acostumbramos mucho a mirar
este lado de lo que está pasando en el
mundo y dejamos de ver lo que pasa en el
otro lado y ahí estoy incluyendo no
solamente a china a rusia a los países
de asia central de hablando de irán
estoy hablando de la india en fin hay
toda una serie de países que tienen
posiciones quizás con matices
sustancialmente distintas esto no quiere
decir que yo no esté en contra de una
condena lo que está pasando lo que digo
es que no terminamos de entender una
nueva dinámica mundial es justamente
putin han entendido muy bien y ha
aprovechado la oportunidad y que ha dado
pasos que parecieran pinceladas muy bien
planeadas andrés sin embargo sin embargo
es que las tropas de eeuu se mantienen
apostadas en polonia sigue existiendo de
todas maneras despliegue grande de la
botana que ha dicho que aumenta sus
flancos alrededor del conflicto que hay
en rusia y ucrania que pueden estar
esperando ante que podrían activarse
no pueden activarse porque ucrania no es
miembro de los tanos
cuál es el mecanismo que pueda
activarlas bueno solamente si realmente
se produce alguna crisis humanitaria de
gran envergadura en ucrania a raíz de mi
invasión rusa no sabemos si eso va a
suceder o no y lo más probable es que si
hay una crisis monetaria en marcha con
el desplazamiento la cantidad de gente
hacia las fronteras para huir de la
guerra pero
eventualmente en mover tropas en su
propio espacio es como en su momento
también les decía en rusia que estaba
moviendo tropas en sus propios espacios
porque eventualmente iba a haber una
invasión inmediata finalmente mi
invasión se produjo pero no sé si esto
mismo se puede plantear en la
perspectiva de lo que pueda ser la otan
o lo que pueda ser la unión europea
parte claramente porque como bien señaló
mi colega dentro de la unión europea
también hay matices diferenciales y a
esto hay que sumar
en cada uno de los países hay posiciones
a veces contrastantes empezando por eeuu
donde acabamos de escuchar hace tres
días al presidente de trump decir que tú
tienes un genio
me gusta ese final que le da su
intervención y me da pie para hablar
ahora con marta porque marta
precisamente le quería preguntar por que
putin está dispuesto a tomar estas
acciones que lo hemos visto decidir en
los últimos días está dispuesto a pagar
el precio por ejemplo de las múltiples
sanciones internacionales está dispuesto
a ver su economía golpeada
cuál es la contraprestación porque sigue
siendo a pesar de todos los bloqueos que
le impondrán otros países y la unión
europea en general porque sigue siendo
para él un buen negocio hacer una
intervención militar en ucrania
por dos razones la primera es ideológica
y la segunda tiene un componente de
política interna a nivel ideológico
para rusia para el presidente putin en
general en particular
ucrania no tiene una razón histórica de
existir como de existir como nación
independiente e independiente forma
parte de la rusia histórica y esa es la
narrativa y lana y la contra la
narrativa a la que ha estado sometiendo
a la población desde los 20 años que
lleva que llevan el careciendo el cargo
en segundo lugar nos tenemos que
remontar quizá a la época del euro que
ayudan a los 2000 a 2015 en ese momento
cuando la sustitución de yanukóvich
para rusia para putin el gobierno que
salió de esas esas manifestaciones de
ese momento es un gobierno ilegítimo un
gobierno neonazi un gobierno que tiene
que eliminar porque el país se ha
convertido en un país neonazi de ahí las
palabras de desnazificación que no deja
de ser una narrativa
para justificarla las acciones que ya
tenía en la mente y en tercer lugar
porque el el hecho de pedir la
desmilitarización de ucrania lo que está
en juego realmente es un problema mayor
y ese es la cuestión de qué pretende
desactivar la posibilidad de que ucrania
en términos militares forme parte de la
otan y forme parte de la unión europea
como tal por lo tanto lo que está en
juego es la desactivación de la otan
llegados a este punto en el que se ve
que en las próximas horas con
y mucha probabilidad va a caer que está
cayendo ya
ciudades importantes como hardcore no le
queda más remedio que seguir
avanzando porque no puede regular no hay
una opción viable para que él pueda
salir fortalecido otra cosa es que la
unión europea viendo que hay una
posición fuerte y que las medidas las
contramedidas
militares pero en este caso
diplomáticas y el cerco militar a las
zonas colindantes a las regiones
colindantes del lado de la otan y
perciba rusia putin perciba la fortaleza
de la unión europea en ese sentido se
repliegue diciendo bueno he conseguido
el objetivo de poner bajo de rodillas a
ruth a australia probablemente voy a
intentar cambiar el régimen pero si no
le pongo de rodillas en el sentido de
que el presidente está lenski
piense dos veces la entrada
en la unión europea y acercarse más a la
otan y pueda replegarse con una
con un poco de dignidad por decirlo de
alguna manera porque solamente el 13 por
ciento de la población en rusia según
las últimas encuestas está criticando la
acción de su presidente por lo que es lo
que significa que esa narrativa y esa
contra narrativa el pueblo ruso se le ha
creído por lo tanto necesita volver a
rusia fortalecido para poder para evitar
el régimen tal caiga de lo contrario
está yendo hacia una salida
loca desequilibrada y puede poner en
riesgo la seguridad internacional con
masa vale decir mi colega porque está
poniendo patas arriba todo el sistema de
seguridad internacional que surgió
después de la guerra fría
bueno andrés vamos a regresar hasta 2014
con las elecciones de crimea después de
la caída de víctor yanukóvich y de una
ruptura en las relaciones hasta ese
momento muy estables entre rusia y entre
ucrania cuando rusia se anexa crimea
pues le retira al país una de sus
provincias más prolíferas uno de sus
principales puntos productivos y todo
esto ante la mirada internacional
imposible porque no llegó a hacerse nada
que pudiera evitar este cambio ahora
esta semana vladimir putin dice una vez
más en un avance que reconoce la
independencia del tomba si no podíamos
ver esto venir no no había manera de
evitar este conflicto que hoy estamos
viviendo
y sin la menor duda se podría haber
previsto un colega mío tritio o algo muy
interesante
para que haya una guerra tiene que haber
tres elementos un agravio
recursos para enfrentarla y
determinación política los agravios
están en la narrativa que justamente
plantea de colegas de útiles son
agravios históricos no solamente por la
separación de ucrania sino por la
amenaza de que sin control es no tan la
promesa de lo tan aparentemente de que
rusia no sería amenazada que viene desde
la década del 90 entonces todo esto
conforma un paquete en otro paquete
obviamente son los recursos yo creo que
en este momento los recursos económicos
y militares
que dispone rusia son recursos
importantes para poder actuar y lo
fundamental es la determinación política
y yo creo que ahí está el problema
justamente de la parte occidental que
falta la determinación política para
actuar eficientemente en una situación
como ésta yo no es que apoye una
decisión de ese tipo más radical por
parte del bloque occidental esté
señalando es que hay tantas ambigüedades
tantas idas y venidas mucha retórica
mucha condena formal
económicas pero en términos de lo que
podría estar haciendo no hay grandes
preguntas hasta dónde va a poder avanzar
pues le agradezco en 3-d agradezco marta
y ya vuelvo con ustedes vamos hasta las
ciudades de kiev de gulliver' y crea
corresponsales de france 24 llegó hasta
la estación de rutger para contarnos de
primera mano la situación de civiles que
están intentando abandonar la capital
ucraniana veamos
muchas personas filas de espera y
confusión de la confusión
de autobuses y carros salen hacia
diferentes puntos de ucrania y también
hacia polonia y otros países de la unión
europea
tengo miedo estoy estresada muy
preocupada quiero regresar
ellos vienen del oeste de ucrania
nuestros hijos están allá sin sus padres
que trabajan en quiebra así que
regresamos para estar con nuestros hijos
de todas formas no hay más trabajo aquí
porque no quedaríamos
mi estado anímico está como el clima de
hoy cambiando sin embargo esos jóvenes
cambiaron de idea miren no podemos
marcharnos de aquí
de dónde viene somos de quien queríamos
irnos pero al final no nosotros nos
quedaremos los lugares escasean y las
personas están nerviosas la gran mayoría
de personas con las que hablé aquí no
tiene ni idea de que les deparará con
respecto a lo que ocurrió este jueves
la crisis desatada tras la incursión
militar rusa en ucrania llevó a varias
naciones entre ellas los países bálticos
a pedir a la otan que se inicie en
consulta o sea para activar el artículo
4 de la alianza con el fin de tomar
decisiones militares cuando uno de los
miembros se siente amenazado ya que
ucraniano es parte del grupo
la novedad
mire ya tiene 23 años y es una sargento
española destinada en la misión de la
otan en letonia su posición es táctica
con su pelotón entrena para disparar en
primera línea de fuego o para mí es un
orgullo estar aquí representando a
españa además a la otra y trabajar como
unidad con la que estado trabajando
todos sus meses anteriores pues también
es como sueño cumplido como usted de
pelota el grupo táctico multinacional de
batalla con base en letonia está
liderado por canadá y albergan 9
nacionalidades distintas el coronel
sanders gauger es el comandante de la
brigada mecanizada letona al cargo de la
base de
la misión se creó hace cinco años para
disuadir y defender es simple todo está
relacionado con la disuasión pero al
mismo tiempo si las cosas van mal es una
misión de defensa aquí
gordon
la lección rusa de crimea precipitó la
creación de tres batallones
internacionales en los países bálticos
que empezaron a operar en 2017
volvemos en directo hacemos
interrupciones para escuchar las
palabras del presidente de estados
unidos joe biden veamos educación sin
justificación sin necesidades
este es un ataque premeditado
vladimir putin estaba planeando esto por
meses y lo estamos diciendo siempre
hemos estado diciendo
175 mil tropas equipo militar estaba
preposición a 2 en toda la frontera con
ucrania él movió suministro de sangre en
posición construyó un hospital de
campaña
es lo que les dice todo lo que tiene que
saber sobre sus intenciones todo el
tiempo ya que el rechazo cada esfuerzo
en buena fe que los estados unidos sus
aliados y socios hicieron para enfrentar
las preocupaciones de seguridad a través
del diálogo para evitar un conflicto
innecesario y evitar el sufrimiento
humano durante semanas durante semanas
hemos estado advirtiendo que esto
pasaría
ahora
se está desenvolviendo como predijimos
la semana pasada vimos bombardeos sobre
el tomba es una región el estado
controlado por separatistas rusos
el gobierno ruso ha perpetrado ataques
sobre la soberanía narco vimos teatros
políticos de significados unas
afirmaciones sin ningún tipo de base que
ucrania iba a invadir y lanzar una
guerra en contra de rusia que ucrania se
estaba preparando para utilizar armas
químicas que ucrania cometió un
genocidio sin ningún tipo de evidencia
hicimos una violación fragrante de la
ley internacional
en intento de crear dos supuestas
repúblicas en territorio ucraniano
soberano
y el mismo momento que el
consejo de seguridad de la naciones
unidas se estaba reuniendo para defender
la soberanía ucraniana putin declaró su
guerra
en solo momentos solo momentos
empezaron a caer misiles sobre ciudades
históricas en todo gran ya entonces
luego vienen los bombardeos aéreos
después de los tanques y las tropas que
empezaron a llegar
hemos sido transparentes con el mundo
hemos compartido evidencia es
clasificada sobre los planes rusos
ciberataques y pretextos para que no
hubiera ninguna confusión o ningún
encubrimiento sobre lo que putin estaba
haciendo putin es el agresor
putin eligió esta guerra y ahora él y su
país tendrán que cargar con las
consecuencias hoy estoy autorizando unas
sanciones adicionales y nuevos límites
sobre lo que puede ser exportado a rusia
esto va a imponer costos severos sobre
la economía rusa tanto inmediatamente
como con el tiempo a propósito hemos
diseñado estas sanciones para maximizar
el impacto de largo plazo de largo plazo
sobre roce minimizar el impacto sobre
eeuu y nuestros aliados quiero dejarlo
muy claro los eeuu no están haciendo
esto solos durante meses hemos estado
construido una coalición de aliados
representando más de la mitad de la
economía global 27 miembros de la unión
europea incluyendo francia alemania
italia así como el reino unido canadá
japón australia nueva zelanda y muchos
otros para amplificar el impacto
conjunto de nuestra respuesta
acabo de hablar con los líderes del g-7
esta mañana y estamos en un consenso
completo limitaremos la capacidad de luz
y hacer negocios en dólares euros libras
y yenes
un intento por hacer parte de la
economía global limitaremos su habilidad
de hacerlo vamos a tener la capacidad de
financiar y aumentar el tamaño del
ejército ruso vamos a imponer
y
vamos a impedir que compitan la economía
el siglo 21 ya hemos visto el impacto de
nuestras acciones en el rublo y en la
economía rusa hoy el ruso llegó a su el
rublo llegó a su nivel más débil en toda
la historia
el mercado bursátil ruso también decayó
hoy
más de un 15 por ciento las acciones de
hoy con esto tenemos sancionado bancos
rusos que conservan más de mil millones
de dólares en bienes hemos congelado el
banco ruso más grande que tienen al
menos un 30 por ciento de toda la
economía rusa por sí mismo la hemos
recortado el sistema financiero de eeuu
y hoy también estamos bloqueando cuatro
bancos más importantes eso significa que
cada bien que ellos tienen en eeuu será
congelado
eso incluye mtb
el segundo mayor banco de rusia que
tiene 250 mil millones de dólares en
activos como prometimos también
agregamos 2
la lista de algunos miembros de la élite
rusa y algunos miembros familiares que
fueron sancionados como lo dije el
martes a estas son personas que ganan
personalmente en las políticas del
kremlin y deberían compartir esta carga
mantendremos este ritmo
hasta que y seguiremos asignando cargas
sobre gente corrupta también hemos
impedido que el gobierno ruso reúna
dinero de
inversionistas estadounidenses o
europeos y vamos a aplicar las lindas
restricciones a las mayores empresas
estatales lusas compañías con bienes que
exceden los 1.4 billones de dólares
algunos de estos impactos superiores se
sentirán con el tiempo a medida que
impedimos el acceso ruso a las finanzas
y la tecnología para sectores
estratégicos de su economía
y similar a un su capacidad industrial
de aquí en años entre estas acciones y
las de nuestros aliados y socios
estimamos que recortaremos más de la
mitad de las importaciones de alta
tecnología de rusia
los golpearemos en sus capacidades de
movilidad de modernizar su ejército y
construir una industria espacial y
afectaremos sus programas aeroespaciales
reduciremos su capacidad de construir
aves y naves y de competir
económicamente eso será un gran golpe a
la ambición estratégica de putin de
largo plazo y estamos preparados para
hacer mucho más
sumado a estas penalidades económicas
también estamos tomando pasos para
defender a nuestros aliados de la otan
particularmente en el este mañana la
otan llamar a una cumbre estaremos ahí
para reunir a los líderes de 30 naciones
aliadas
socios cercanos para reafirmar nuestra
solidaridad y para trazar los siguientes
pasos que vamos a tomar para fortalecer
todos los aspectos de nuestra alianza de
lo tanto aunque hemos entregado
650 millones de dólares en ayuda de
seguridad para ucrania este año el año
pasado de md siglo de nuevo nuestras
fuerzas no
entrarán en el conflicto con rusia en
ucrania nuestras fuerzas no van a ir a
europa para luchar en ucrania sino para
defender a nuestros aliados delatan y
reafirmarle a esos aliados en el este
como he dejado claro los eeuu dependerán
cada pulgada de territorio de la otan
con toda la fuerza del pueblo
estadounidense de poder estadounidense
las noticias de noticias son que la otan
ahora está más unida y más determinada
que nunca antes no hay ninguna duda
ninguna duda de que los estados unidos y
cada aliado de la otan
cumplirá con sus compromisos de artículo
5 que dice que un ataque sobre unos son
ataque sobre todo durante las últimas
semanas
por enviado miles de tropas más a
alemania polonia como parte nuestro
compromiso con otan el martes en
respuesta a la agresión
de rusia
el despliegue en bielorrusia el mar
negro ya hemos desplegado más tropas y
nuestros aliados del blanco este estonia
letonia lituania polonia y rumanía
nuestros aliados también han estado
aumentando su comprensión
el resto de la otan
agregó sus fuerzas y sus capacidades
para asegurar una defensa colectiva y
hoy
apenas horas después del asalto de rusia
la otan se reunió y autorizó y activó
una los planes de respuesta
esto muestra
la prontitud con la que la otan puede
desplegarse donde se le necesite para
proteger a nuestros aliados de la otan
incluso en las fronteras es desde europa
ahora estoy autorizando unas fuerzas
adicionales de eeuu que vayan a alemania
como parte de la respuesta del otan
incluyendo parte de las
tropas que se designaron en esperas unas
cuantas semanas también agregó el
secretario zinc y el general milk y
sobre preparaciones por posibles otros
movimientos que se requieran para
defender a nuestros aliados de la otan y
respaldar la mayor alianza militar en la
historia del mundo la otan
a medida que respondemos la
administración está utilizando cada
herramienta posible para proteger a las
familias y negocios estadounidenses de
los precios crecientes hemos tomado
pasos para disminuir el costo sobre el
petróleo sobre petróleo y el gas
estadounidense estas compañías no
deberían disfrutar el momento para
aumentar sus ganancias
nuestro paquete de sanciones
específicamente diseñados
el pago de energía
también estamos monitoreando los costos
del día por cualquier tipo de reacción
estamos coordinando con países
productores de petróleo para asegurar un
suministro global de energía estamos
trabajando activamente con países
alrededor de mundo para elevar
sí
para habilitar las reservas de presos
ligas en todo el mundo también eeuu está
liberando más barriles de petróleo ya
que las condiciones empeoran y sé que
esto es difícil sé que los
estadounidenses ya están sintiendo el
golpe y yo voy a hacer todo lo que esté
en mi poder para limitar el poder que el
pueblo estadounidense está sintiendo en
las bombas de gasolina esto para mí es
crítico pero esta agresión no puede no
ser respondida
las consecuencias para estados unidos
serían mucho peor eeuu está se defiende
de los matones defiende la libertad de
esto es lo que somos
también quiero repetir la advertencia
que hice la semana pasada si rusia busca
hacer ciudad ataques en contra de estas
compañías su infraestructura crítica
estamos bien parados para responder
durante meses hemos estado trabajando de
cerca con el sector privado para
aumentar nuestra nivel defensas tuvieron
esta capacidad de responder a los
ataques rusos también hablé anoche con
el presidente es elegido ucrania y le
asegure que los eeuu junto con nuestros
aliados y socios en europa respaldaremos
al pueblo ucraniano mientras defienden a
su país mm h live
les daremos ayuda humanitaria para
aliviar su sufrimiento
los primeros días de ese conflicto la
propaganda rusa seguirá intentando
ocultar la verdad
diciendo que están siendo exitosos
en sus aventuras militares encontrado
una vena cimentada provisoria mostrado
una y otra vez como las rápidas
ganancias en el terreno
llevan a ocupaciones complicadas a una
desobediencia civil masiva y bueno
caminos cerrados en la estratégica en
las próximas semanas y meses
con esto
putin ha liberado un montón de dolor
sobre la gente ucraniana pero la gente
ucraniana ya conoce al menos 30 años de
independencia y ha repetido que no van a
tolerar que nadie intente hacer que su
país vuelva a hacer lo que fue este es
un momento peligroso para toda europa y
para la libertad en todo el mundo putin
ha cometido un asalto contra los
principios que sostienen la paz mundial
pero ahora el mundo entero está viéndolo
con claridad
putin el kremlin y sus aliados del
kremlin bueno ya sabe el mundo como son
esto no fue nunca un tema de seguridad
de su parte siempre era una agresión
descarada el deseo de putin de tener un
imperio fuera como fuera al matonear a
los vecinos de rubia de rusia y hacer
los corruptos a cambiar las cosas por la
fuerza al elegir la guerra sin una causa
las acciones de putin
ponen en compromiso el mundo el futuro
del mundo su visión
[Música]
los eeuu y sus aliados y socios
emergerán de esta situación más fuertes
más unidos más determinados con un mayor
propósito la agresión de putin en contra
de ucrania terminará costándole a rusia
mucho económicamente y estratégicamente
nos aseguraremos de eso
putin será un paria en el escenario
internacional cualquier nación
que valore esta agresión será manchada
por la asociación
la historia está siendo escrita en la
elección de putin de hacer una guerra
totalmente injustificable el sol ucrania
y dejará a rusia mucho más débil y al
mundo al resto del mundo mucho más
fuerte la libertad la democracia la
dignidad humana estas son las fuerzas
son fuerzas mucho más poderosas que el
miedo y la opresión
no pueden ser extinguidas por tiranos
como putin y sus ejércitos
no pueden ser borradas de los corazones
de las personas de las esperanzas de las
personas sin importar la intimidación a
la violencia persisten
en la disputa entre la democracia y
autocracia entre la soberanía y la
subyugación no cometan ningún error acá
no se confundan la libertad prevalecerá
dios bendiga al pueblo de una ucrania
libre y democracia y que dios proteja
nuestras tropas
soy yo
ap
tiene planes de hablar con el presidente
putin en este punto y qué interacciones
ha tenido con el gobierno ruso escuché
la primera parte tengo planes de hablar
con el presidente podría en este punto y
que comunicación tiene un set con
es un conflicto bastante grande ahora
que queremos asegurarnos de que no
resulta en un conflicto grande y la
manera es reuniendo todas las fuerzas
necesarias en las naciones del este de
europa y los miembros del otan la otan
es más unida de lo que nunca ha estado y
no tengo ningún plan de hablar con putin
el sitio no
termina
señor presidente usted no mencionó el
sistema swift en las sanciones hay
alguna razón por la cual los eeuu no
esté haciendo eso hay un desacuerdo
entre aliados
respecto del sistema swift y si rusia
debe hacer parte de las sanciones que
estamos proponiendo sobre los bancos
tienen una consecuencia igual tiene
mayores consecuencias incluso que swift
en primer lugar en segundo lugar siempre
es una opción pero ahora esa no es la
posición del resto de europa
no sé si habéis
cecilia vega abc
señor las sanciones han sido suficientes
para disuadir a vladimir putin de
avanzar este punto que es lo que lo va a
detener como
y cuando termina esto ve usted que él
quiera ir más allá de ucrania en la
segunda pregunta está la declaración que
él dio anoche la amenaza que emitió que
el occidente apenas tiene unas posibles
consecuencias superiores está en la
manzana con un golpe nuclear no tengo
idea cuál es su amenaza sé qué es lo que
ha hecho en primer lugar en segundo
lugar nadie esperaba que las sanciones
previnieran que algo sucediera
esto puede tomar tiempo y tenemos que
mostrar
determinación él sabe qué es lo que
viene entonces la gente de rusia sabe
qué es lo que ha pasado y qué es lo que
le ha traído de eso es que se trata esto
esto va a tomar tiempo no va a ocurrir
en no decir por dios estas acciones
vienen voy a tener gérmenes no vuelva a
probar la determinación del occidente y
nosotros vamos a mantenernos unidos
y vamos a causarle cosas puede que vaya
más allá genia sí
dos temas rápidamente primer lugar los
mercados están en decaída los precios
están aumentando en el gas sé que usted
habla de la diferencia entre wall street
y main suite pero todo el mundo parece
bueno empezar a sufrir las desventajas
económicas con qué tan difícil
económicamente sea poner para la gente
este país y tengo una pregunta más en
primer lugar no hay ninguna duda de que
cuando un gran poder nuclear
ataca e invade a otro país que el mundo
va a responder y los mercados pueden
responder en todo el mundo entonces no
hay ninguna duda
en primer lugar en segundo lugar
la noción de que esto vaya a durar por
un tiempo prolongado es bastante
improbable medida que sigamos
determinados imponiendo las sanciones
que vamos a imponer
sobre rusia punto cual es su siguiente
pregunta la siguiente pregunta es acaso
usted subestimó a putin no escribiría
todavía como lo hizo en el verano como
un adversario valeroso en ese momento él
lo era y yo lo dejé claro como
empresario y dije que una persona
valerosa nunca lo suben si me he leído
la mayor parte de lo que el escrito no
no no estoy bueno usted ha escuchado el
discurso que él dijo apenas bueno unas
horas de porque él iba a ir a ucrania él
tiene unas ambiciones superiores en
ucrania él quiere realmente reestablecer
la anterior unión soviética de eso se
trata esto y creo que sus ambiciones son
completamente contrarias al lugar en el
que está el resto del mundo
usted tiene confianza de que estas
sanciones devastadoras vayan a ser tan
devastadoras como los misiles y las
balas y los tanques rusos
las balas misiles y tanques rusos en
ucrania sí seguro
presidente by den si las sanciones no
pueden detener al presidente putin qué
tipo de penalidad puede hacerlo yo no
dije que las sanciones pudieran
detenerlo usted está hablando de la
fuerza de estas sanciones por semanas sí
pero las amenazas de las sanciones y la
imposición de sanciones el efecto de las
sanciones y ver esos efectos son cosas
diferentes son cosas diferentes
y lo que va a pasar es que él empezará a
ver los efectos de las sanciones que
hará eso como cambiará eso su situación
por que debilitarán a su país tanto que
él tendrá que hacer una decisión muy
difícil
o se convierte en un segundo poder o
responde usted dice que las grandes
naciones no pueden bloquear cuando se
trata de esto se estableció esa idea
personalmente hablando de que las
sanciones personales a putin eran
estaban en la mesa bueno hay muchas
cosas que están en la mesa sancionar al
presidente putin sí porque no
sancionarlo hoy señor
porque no sancionarlo
señor presidente si puede usted detalló
unas sanciones severas
habló del impacto duradero que tendría
pero a la invasión de gran escala dado
que usted no está persiguiendo una
desconexión de rusia lo que se llama
swift sistema bancario internacional u
otras sanciones a su disposición
respetuosamente el señor que más está
esperando usted específicamente con las
sanciones que hemos impuesto esto excede
swift excede cualquier cosa que se haya
hecho antes de las sanciones que
impusimos han generado dos tercios
ángeles ya que dos tercios del mundo se
une a nosotros sus acciones profundas
tengamos una conversación en un mes o
dos y veremos si está funcionando puedan
preguntarle por sabes que usted habló
con vladimir celestes que ayer
cuál es el riesgo
de que estemos viendo el inicio de una
segunda guerra fría y acaso hay una
ruptura total entre la relación de rusia
y eeuu hay una ruptura total en las
relaciones entre eeuu y dioses y
continúan en este camino
en términos de guerra fría eso depende
tiene la vasta mayoría del resto del
mundo en completa posición con lo que él
está haciendo desde asia hasta
sudamérica hasta europa y en todo
alrededor del mundo entonces
va a ser un día muy frío para rusia la
idea ustedes no ver a mucha gente que
esté yendo a defenderlo
quiero hacer seguimiento de estado usted
dirigiendo a china ayudar a aislar a
rusia está pidiéndole ustedes o china
no estoy preparado para comentar eso en
estos momentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
él tenía en su mano más levantada sí sí
gracias presidente que tanto le preocupa
que putin quiera ir más allá de ucrania
a otros países eeuu / involucrarle e
involucrarse siete países de la otan si
él entra países pero también tendríamos
que ser involucrados estaremos
involucrados lo único de lo que estoy
convencido es que si no lo detenemos
ahora él estará envalentonado pero si
nos movemos ahora con esas sanciones
significativas él se verá envalentonado
miren
cada
cualquiera
puede hablar más de su conversación ser
presidente
[Música]
porque no sancionan a putin directamente
los centros por escuchar
dónde
en día es uno de sus mayores de fin
aliados en defensa está en sincronía con
lo decidido con eeuu estamos en consulta
con india hoy no hemos resuelto este
tema completamente
y muchas gracias a todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
los 24 para su edición en español en
directo para toda américa latina ustedes
pueden seguirnos a través de nuestras
redes sociales y también a través de
nuestro canal en youtube y con nuestros
aliados en los servicios de televisión
regionales vamos a regresar muy
rápidamente para conclusiones después de
las palabras de joe biden con marta
gonzález y andrés servín los analistas
que amablemente nos han acompañado
durante este cubrimiento en esta tarde
marta comienzo con ustedes que decir
después de este anuncio tan esperado de
joe biden
bueno varias caen varias cosas ha
señalado puntos muy interesantes ha sido
un discurso bastante contundente y yo
creo que estaba dirigido en dos
direcciones a la pobre a la población a
eeuu para en el sentido de decirles hoy
un líder contundente serio y ejerce el
liderazgo internacional en un momento en
el que su liderazgo está seriamente
comprometido y a nivel externo
directamente a putin para decirle somos
una potencia somos capaces de aunar el
consenso internacional estás aislado y
es probable que si no recules y tomemos
nota y tomemos
nota y demos pasos contundentes en ese
sentido me gustaría
señalar otras cuestiones que ha puesto
sobre la mesa en primer lugar ha dicho
que va a defender la seguridad de los
países de la otan
que no va a entrar en ucrania yo creo
que eso es importante por una razón
porque no se va a activar el artículo 5
del tratado de la otan -que salvo en el
caso de que rusia ataque uno de los
países directamente involucrados en la
otan como puedan ser
estonia letonia lituania es decir los
bálticos o entre en polonia en ese
sentido si no da ese paso el presidente
putin y ucrania está fuera del paraguas
de la otan y por lo tanto de una acción
militar coordinada por parte de la otan
y en segundo lugar me gustaría señalar
algo que es importante en el tema de que
se está tratando en estos meses en el
sentido de la nueva estrategia de
seguridad de la alianza como saben cada
día a cada diez años la alianza se
recompone este año toca en junio una
reunión de la alianza para establecer la
nueva estrategia de seguridad hasta este
momento en los últimos años la alianza
y ha dejado de ser una alianza puramente
militar para establecerse en el campo
más de lo del respeto de los derechos
humanos incluso muy contestada por parte
de analistas estaba usted dirigiéndose
hacia el campo del respeto del cambio
climático una cuestión que no compete a
una organización militar por lo tanto
esta situación de crisis lo que está
recomponiendo otra vez es el papel
militar de la otan que nunca debió
perderse sí creo que aunque el
presidente de airén ha dicho que rompe
el diálogo con putin yo sí creo que le
está dejando una puerta abierta al
presidente para que salga de esta
situación con un cierto honor y evitar
en su patio interno haya una revuelta
porque lo que él está diciendo
soterradamente es si no cede a las
presiones de la comunidad internacional
que parece que si hay consenso
pensar que rusia está aislada yo
solamente te basta aislar
internacionalmente
sino que vamos a provocar la caída de tu
régimen a partir de revueltas internas
bueno y entre ese de su opinión por
favor después de escuchar la
intervención de joe biden
pero yo creo que había mencionado mi
comentario anterior en el tema de la
determinación política
yo creo que por muchas las respuestas
que ha dado las preguntas de los
periodistas aquí faltan ciertos grados
de determinación política primero
muestra que no hay un acuerdo completo
particularmente en el tema de swift con
algunos aliados segundo cuando se le
pregunta por la posición de china no
estoy preparado para hablar de ello la
posición de india buena estamos hablando
sobre este tema entonces en el sentido
de la comunidad internacional
respaldando enteramente cualquier
decisión está bajo siguiente relación
además de esto yo creo que en el otro
tema yo concuerdo con los comentarios
finales de mi colega pero hay otros
temas que si no hay que perder de vista
y es que en
este en esa situación de tensión la
lógica que ha estado aplicando el
occidente y particularmente eeuu es una
lógica fundamentalmente económica vamos
a presionar vamos a sancionar
económicamente y con eso vamos a ahogar
la economía rusa la lógica de putin es
completamente distinta es la lógica del
y hay un viejo dicho ruso y con esto
cierro que dice muy claramente el oro
dijo yo compro todo y la espada dijo yo
tomo todo
pues bien quisiera que no terminara
todavía porque después de esto pues
tengo más preguntas a partir de lo que
dice una de las declaraciones del
presidente joe biden ante las preguntas
de los reporteros que usted mencionaba
era que putin lo que quiere decir volver
a la territorialidad que vimos alguna
vez en la unión soviética usted cree que
ese es su objetivo y más allá de eso
cree que esto es algo factible realista
es muy brevemente dos elementos primero
lo que quieres putin es garantizar un
área de influencia algo de lo que no se
hablaba después de la caída de la unión
soviética y que es fundamental para la
preservación desde la perspectiva de
putin de la seguridad de la federación
rusa y en segundo elemento que más que
recordar es una reconstitución de la
unión soviética y putin ha sido bastante
crítico con respecto a la unión
soviética de varios elementos
recientemente más bien da la impresión
de que está recreando un nuevo
nacionalismo ruso más bien arraigado en
su momento en el imperio ruso previo a
la unión soviética y esto tiene
resonancias muy importantes en una gran
parte de la población rusa por eso en la
encuesta que llevó una de
uno de los medios de prensa muestra que
más del 50 por ciento de la población
rusa lo respalda esto no quita que sea
una posición monolítica no todos lo
respaldan
navalny que no de sus declaraciones
recientes en el disidente y de opositor
ha dicho muy claramente que este paso de
putin va a llegar a un segundo
organizado según el afganistán de
aquella época llegó a la destrucción de
la unión soviética por lo tanto hoy
mismo ha habido manifestaciones de moscú
en contra de la guerra nada es
monolítico de lado y lado hay que
entender los matices que están en juego
qué intereses están en juego para poder
entender como esto puede ir avanzando
hacia adelante hacia algún destino
esperemos mejor y eso es lo que estamos
intentando hacer aquí de la mano de
ustedes un agradecimiento muy grande
para usted andrew es un agradecimiento
también muy grande para marta gonzález
por la paciencia y por estar con
nosotros a lo largo de toda esta
transmisión una noticia que está en
desarrollo y sobre la que solamente
podemos ir analizando conforme llegan
nuevas noticias después de este
agradecimiento para nuestros dos
invitados y de liberarlos por el momento
quisiera ahora irme hasta washington
para conversar al corner nuestro
corresponsal de cristóbal a vázquez
cristóbal una declaración larga la que
dio vice de n digamos fuerte en algunos
sentidos aunque según lo evidenciaron
los periodistas presentes en la rueda de
prensa hay bastantes vacíos sobre la
respuesta que va a dar eeuu una de las
preguntas que fue más insistente y que
él no quiso responder que ignoró
deliberadamente fue porque no sancionar
directamente a vladimir putin hoy mismo
exacto después de que había dicho
durante varias semanas que las sanciones
ya van a ser severas contra rusia contra
las élites rusas contra el gobierno ruso
no hubo esas sanciones directamente
contra vladimir putin muchos analistas
sin embargo están diciendo que pues es
limitado el efecto que puede tener ya
todas estas sanciones a rusia por un
lado porque vladimir putin pues ya ha
preparado durante varios años a su
pueblo a sufrir precisamente el efecto
de estas sanciones no queda claro
tampoco pues el compromiso militar de
eeuu con ucrania yo bailé en este
discurso dejó claro que eeuu no va a ir
a pelear contra rusia en ucrania que no
va a enviar tropas a ucrania para luchar
directamente contra las fuerzas
militares rusas pero que va a proteger a
los aliados de la otan en ese sentido
pues anunció que mañana habrá una cumbre
de los países de la otan y los países de
otros países invitados también
se definirá por ellos una estrategia aún
más más fuerte más contundente contra
rusia pero que precisamente mañana en
esta cumbre pues ahora también noticias
sobre movimientos de tropas seguramente
que se harán en los países de la otan y
sobre otras estrategias militares de
cara a esta avanzada de rusia en ucrania
entre otras de otro centro entre otros
detalles conocemos por ejemplo que ya
chernóbil ya está en control de los
rusos esta es una zona pues muy polémica
históricamente y además muy cerca la
capital y pues es de resaltar también
estas sanciones económicas no solamente
estos anuncios militares estos anuncios
de apoyo a los países de la otan pero a
nivel económico también se esperaba un
pronunciamiento de pronto un poco más
duro por parte de joe biden por ejemplo
considerar cortar a rusia de el sistema
swift del sistema financiero bancario
global sin embargo pues yo bayern
anunció que serán nuevamente los bancos
bancos principales en rusia los tengan
pues los que sean más afectados por
estas sanciones dijo que él va a limitar
la posibilidad de que estas
instituciones financieras bancarias
rusas puedan seguir negociando en las
principales divisas de occidente el euro
y el dólar claramente y otras monedas
también de occidente y dijo que estas
sanciones van a limitar también el
crecimiento de la tecnología rusa el
crecimiento militar y también van a
afectar a empresas privadas de empresas
privadas que se han beneficiado en los
últimos años por las políticas de
vladimir putin que pues se han podido
crecer de forma pues bastante
pronunciada debido a ese vínculo que
tiene vladimir putin con algunos
oligarcas rusos y estas empresas
entonces decía yo bailé en este largo
discurso pues tienen activos por más de
un billón de dólares y serían también
afectadas pero pues lo que varios están
diciendo varios analistas están diciendo
es que pues se esperaba una respuesta a
nivel financiero
duro si son cuatro bancos más que están
financiados que sus activos en eeuu
además quedan congelados pero pues se
esperaba una sanción mucho más directa a
vladimir putin no solamente en términos
financieros sino también en en
movimientos
militares de forma más concreta por
parte del presidente estadounidense
muy bien y finalmente cristóbal también
quería preguntarle ya que ustedes me
está poniendo el tema del swift si en su
opinión es una petición desproporcionada
de ucrania este llamado a sacarlos de
este sistema económico usted qué opina
pues es desproporcionada pues es que hay
que ponerse también en el papel de lo
que está pasando en ucrania los líderes
ucranianos obviamente están tratando de
avanzar en
mayor medida pues unas sanciones
bastante fuertes para tratar de
limitar esta avanzada de rusia lo que
pasa es que pues al sancionar y al
congelar a rusia del sistema swift es
uno de los países más afectados
precisamente sería estados unidos y
alemania grandes potencias económicas y
pues al al al limitar este a limitar a
rusia el sistema swift pues se
congelarían además los pagos
a empresas rusas petroleras y de gas y
esto pues tendría graves efectos en el
mercado energético que en este momento y
lo mencionó yo vayan en su discurso lo
que precisamente quiere evitarse o
bailén es que el estadounidense promedio
se vea afectado precisamente por estas
medidas es decir yo bailé está jugando
aquí un poco un malabar a tratar de sí
asumir una posición futura frente a
rusia de cara a esta invasión a ucrania
pero al mismo tiempo pues limitar los
efectos internos que tenga la exposición
que asuma eeuu frente a este conflicto
en ucrania y eso es una línea gris
bastante difícil y bastante complicada
de caminar porque precisamente si los
precios de la gasolina con eeuu han
aumentado por encima del 20 por ciento
en el último año y la inflación está por
encima del 7 casi el 8 por ciento en
algunos productos supera el 15 por
ciento pues este tipo de sanciones
financieras y sanciones aún más fuertes
que se podrían venir en el futuro
tendrían graves efectos en la economía
estadounidense
y posiblemente la votación al congreso
que le importa mucho con eeuu porque el
partido demócrata quiere lograr mantener
la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes y una economía débil o
una inflación alta a altos precios de la
gasolina pues no representan muchos
votos de cara a esta elección
legislativa en noviembre de este año
puesto que hemos dicho ya cristóbal y es
que no solamente se trata de los
beneficios o de los problemas que traiga
para ucrania sino para cada país que
está involucrado una cosa que le quería
preguntar hace un rato era cómo resuena
esta noticia del ataque de rusia sobre
ucrania en eeuu porque si bien desde el
gobierno pues eeuu es uno de los actores
internacionales
más importantes y de quien más se espera
una respuesta dura pues esto realmente
para usted ha causado un efecto fuerte
en la ciudadanía está preocupada la
ciudadanía estadounidense por lo que
está pasando al otro lado del mundo
si de hecho caminando hacia acá hacia la
casa blanca los guardias de seguridad la
policía metropolitana obviamente
conversando entre ellas logré escuchar
una de las conversaciones y lo que lo
que mucha gente comenta es si este es o
no el principio de una guerra mundial de
una tercera guerra mundial es
constantemente el argumento que se
escucha y si css vieron por ejemplo
manifestaciones de rusos y ucranianos al
frente de la embajada de rusia acá en
washington a pocas cuadras de acá de la
casa blanca y si es la preocupación del
ciudadano que constantemente conversando
entre ellos en
grupos de redes sociales es eficiente la
atención acá en la ciudad se siente
además la atención en las calles ay ay
ay ay ay hay cierta ciertas y cierta
seguridad que se ha aumentado y pues
obviamente es lo que mucha gente está
haciendo emprendiendo sus medios de
comunicación para informarse estar
atento a lo que está pasando ya estas
último desarrollos y estas decisiones
que toma el gobierno de eeuu que tendría
repercusiones en el día a día de los
estadounidenses y yo creo que en este
momento cuando eeuu sale de la guerra de
afganistán y le cuesta tanto al gobierno
de joe biden esta salida y sigue esta
línea de empezar a pensar más en los
intereses de eeuu
cuesta pensar y muchos colegas con los
que ha hablado y amigos con los que ha
hablado acá dicen no puede ser que otra
vez estemos involucrados en un en una
guerra internacional en un conflicto
externo que traiga aún más costos para
los estadounidenses cuando la retórica
cuando el interés durante los últimos
años ha sido centrémonos en los
problemas que tenemos internamente
quiso el gracias a usted por su análisis
y por su reporte desde washington el dc
en eeuu con esta intervención no pues
hemos llegado al final de esta etapa de
nuestro cubrimiento especial es sobre la
crisis entre rusia y ucrania la noticia
sigue siendo la misma rusia atacó
ucrania lo estamos viendo desde la noche
anterior a las 10 de la noche hora de
bogotá quito lima france24 empezó con
este cubrimiento incansable con la
disposición de todo su equipo
periodístico y técnico para traerles a
ustedes las informaciones en directo de
cómo avanza la situación sobre este
conflicto bélico que no veíamos uno como
el e probablemente desde la segunda
guerra mundial gracias a ustedes por
estar con nosotros en france 24 y
también en france 24 punto com no
olviden que pueden actualizar las
noticias en minuto a minuto en nuestro
sitio web con las informaciones de
nuestros periodistas eso es todo por el
momento ya viene valentina torre sánchez
con el nuestro informativo de la tarde y
más adelante continuamos con este
cubrimiento feliz tarde
[Música]